Delivery Search-
Friendly JavaScript -powered by
Websites
>> Welcome. Thank you
for joining.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> TOM GREENAWAY: Good
morning, everyone.
My name it Tom greenway, and I'm
a partner developer advocate
from Google
Sydney with a focus on
progressiveibility of web
applications.
>> JOHN MUELLER: I'm John
Mueller, an analyst from Zurich
and Switzerland.  It's great to
see so many of you here, even at
this early hour.
>> TOM GREENAWAY: Now, as you
can imagine, John and I have a
lot of experience the work web
developers must do to ensure
websites are indexable, which is
another way of saying if a web
page can be found and understood
by search engines, but do search
engines see all web pages
exactly the same way, as some
pages are more complex than
others?  And what about modern
JavaScript powered websites?
Today we'll be taking a closer
look into what it takes for a
modern JavaScript powered
website to be searched by search
scrollers and especially Google
Search.
In this talk, we're announcing a
bunch of new talk, including a
new change to Google search
policy and new approach for
rendering HTML to search
crawlers and even a new Google
tool.
It sounds lining a lot of stuff,
right?  That's because it is.
Let's get started.
Now, a long time ago,
before I joined Google, I was
building eCommerce sites, and I
personally felt there was a lot
of mystery at times behind
Google Search, especially on the
topic of indexibility.  I would
wonder why do some of my pages
appear in Google Search and some
don't and what's the difference
between them?
Will JavaScript be rendered
correctly, will JavaScript
rendered content appear properly
and be indexed, and is lazy
loading an image safe to do?
These are really critical
questions, and as developers
ourselves, we understand the
frustration behind this mystery,
so today John and I are going to
do something we very rarely do
at Google, we're going to pull
back the curtain a little bit
and reveal some new pieces of
information about how Google
Search sees the web and indexes
it, and with this new knowledge
and a few new tools, you'll have
concrete steps you can take to
ensure that JavaScript-powered
websites you're
building are visible to Google
Search.
Now, I want to remind you that
this talk is about modern
JavaScript-powered websites, and
typically these websites will be
powered by JavaScript framework,
such as
Angular, Polimer or react.  Who
doesn't love a framework that's
easy to use and helps you build
your sites faster and works
great for your users?  But it's
important to recognize that some
of these frameworks use a
single-page app configuration
model,
meaning they use a single HTML
file that pulls in a bunch of
JavaScript, and that can make
stuff simpler, but if you don't
watch out, JavaScript-powered
websites can be a problem for
search engines.
Let's take a look at what a new
Angular project looks like.  As
you can see the default project
template is pretty basic.  It
shows you how to use Angular to
render a header, and a few
links.  Nice and simple.  How
could this possibly be a problem
from an indexibility
perspective?
Let's take a peek behind the
scenes at the HTML.  This is it.
Take a good look.  When viewed
in the browser, the default
browser context had text,
imagery, and links, but you
wouldn't know this by looking at
this initial HTML that's been
delivered from the server.  The
initial HTML that's been sent
down is completely devoid of any
content.  See here in the app
root?  That's all there is in
the body of the
page except for some script
tags, so some search engines
might assume that
there's actually nothing here to
index.  And to be clear clear,
angular isn't the only framework
that serves an empty response on
its initial service side render.
Others have similar issues by
default.  What does this mean
for the indexibility of our
websites from the perspective of
Google Search?
Well, to answer that question
better, we'll take a little step
back and talk about the web in
general, why
search engines exist, and why
search crawlers are necessary.
Perhaps a good question to start
with is how big is the web?
Well, we can tell you that we've
weave actually found over 10
trillion -- we've actually found
over 130 trillion documents on
the web.  In other words, it's
really big, and the aim of all
search engines, including
Google, is to provide a list of
relevant
search results based on a user's
search
queryy, and to make that search
result fast and accurate, we
need an index, similar to the
catalog of a gigantic library,
and given the size of the web,
that's a really complex task.
So to build this index,
to power our search engine, we
need another tool, a search
crawler, and traditionally a
search crawler was basically
just a computer and piece of
software that performed two key
steps.  One, it aims to find a
piece of content to be crawled,
and to do this,
the content must be retrievable
by a URL, and once we have a
URL, we search through the HTML
to index the page and find new
links to crawl as well, and
thus, the cycle repeats.
So let's look at that first
step, the crawling, and break it
down.  Oh, and yes, and as an
Australian, I thought it was
imperative that I include some
spiders in my talk.  This was
the cutest possible one I could
find.  John, what do you think?
IsYou're not convinced?  I have
a few more in the deck.  Maybe
you'll come around.
So to ensure crawling is
possible, there are key things
to keep in mind.
Firstly, we need URLs to be
reachable, in there shouldn't be
any issue once the crawler wants
to retrieve the web pages
and retrieve things to index
them.  If there are multiple
documents that contain the same
content, we need a way to
identify the original source, or
it could be interpreted as
duplicate content.  Finally, we
want our web pages to have
clean, unique URLs.  This was
pretty straightforward on the
web, but the first single page
apps made things a bit more
complicated, so let's go over
each of these concepts.
First, for the reachibility of
URLs, this is simple a standard
way to help search engines find
content that you're probably
familiar with.
You add a plain text file called
robot.
text which specifies which URLs
to use and which ones to ignore.
This can spree vent JavaScript
being crawled too, which could
affect your indexibility.  This
example gives us a link to a
site map.  It helps crawlers by
providing a recommended set of
URLs to crawl initially for a
site, and to be clear, there's
no guarantee these URLs will get
crawled, they're just one of the
signals
that search crawlers will
consider .
Okay.  But now let's talk about
that duplicate content scenario
and how search crawlers deal
with this situation.  Sometimes
websites want multiple pages to
have the same content, right,
even if it's a different
website.
For example, bloggers will
publish articles on their
website and cross-post
to services like media to
increase the reach of their
content, and this is called
content syndication.  It's
important for search crawlers to
understand which URL you prefer
to have
indexed, so they can order
metadata search index, and it
allows the documents to
communicate to crawlers where
the source for the content
lives.
We call that source document the
conocal document.
And tra deductiblely $GS for the
web started out quite simple.
A URL was to a server with HTML,
and Ajax came along and changed
everything.  Suddenly websites
could execute JavaScript, which
could fetch new content from the
server without reloading the
browser page, but developers
wanted a way to support back and
forward browser navigation and
history as well, so a trick was
invented which leveraged
something called the fragment
identifier, and its purpose is
for deep linking into the soft
content
of a page, like a subsection of
an encyclopedia article.
Because it was supported by
browsers for history and
navigation, this meant
developers could trick the
browser into fetching new
content dynamically without
reloading the browser page and
yet support the history and
navigation we love about the
web, but we realized using the
fragment identifier for two
purposes, subsections on pages
and also deep linking into
content, it wasn't very elegant,
so we moved away from that, and
instead, another approach was
proposed, to use the fragment
identifier, followed by an
exclamation mark, which we
called the hash bang, and this
way we could discern the
difference
between a traditional URL using
the fragment identifier for the
subcontent on a page, vs.
the fragmenter be used by
JavaScript to use a deep link
into a panel.  This technique
was recommended for a while.
However, nowadays there is a
modern day JavaScript API that
makes these old techniques
unnecessary, and it's called the
history API.  It's great because
it enables managing the history
state of the URL without
requiring reload of the browser,
all
through JavaScript, so we get
the best of both worlds.  And I
can tell you from dwooling's
perspective, we no longer index
that single hash work-around and
we discourage the use of the
hash bank
trick as well .
Okay.  That's crawling
out of the way.  Let's move on
to the indexing step.
So web crawlers ideally want to
be able to find all the content
on your website.  If the
crawlers can't see some content,
how are they going to index it?
The core content of the page
includes all the text, imagery,
video, and hidden elements, like
structured metadata.  In other
words, it's the HTML of the
page.  But don't forget about
that content you dynamically
fetch either.  This could be
worth indexing as well, such as
Facebook or discuss comments.
Crawlers want to see this
embedded content too.
And also this might seem
really obvious, but I want to
emphasize that at
Google, we take HTTP codes
pretty seriously, especially 404
not found codes.
If crawlers find a page that has
a 404 status code, they probably
won't bother indexing it.  The
lastly, a crawler wants to find
all the links on the page
because these links allow the
crawler to crawl further.
So now let's just talk a
bit about those links quickly,
because they're some of the most
important parts of the web.  How
do search crawlers like Google
find links?  Well, I can't speak
for all search crawlers, but I
can say that at Google, we only
analyze one thing, anchor tags
with HREF attributes, and that's
it.  For example, this band here
that I've just added, it won't
get crawled because
it's not an anchor, and this
additional
span I've added, it doesn't have
an HREF attribute.  But if you
are using JavaScript, such as
with the history API that I
mentioned earlier, to navigate
the page, purely on the client
and fetch view contact
dynamically, you can do that so
long as you use the anchor tags
with HREF attributes like in the
last example because most search
crawlers, including Google, will
not simulate navigation of a
page to find links, only the
anchor
tags will be followed for
linking.
Oh, wait, is that really
everything?
In order to have sifted through
the HTML to index the panel, we
needed to have the HTML in the
first place.  In the early days,
the server likely gave us all
the HTML that was necessary, but
today that's not the case.
Let's insert a step between
crawling and indexing because we
need to recognize the search
crawlers themselves might need
to take on this rendering task
as well, otherwise how will the
search crawler understand the
modern JavaScript-powered
websites we're building?
Because these sites are
rendering their HTML in the
browser themselves using
JavaScript and template
frameworks, just like the
example I showed you earlier.
When I say rendering, I
don't mean drawing pixels to the
screen, I'm talking about the
actual construction of the HTML
itself, and ultimately this is
only can ever happen on either
the server or the client or a
combination of the two could be
used, and we call that hybrid
rendering.
Now, if it's all prerendered on
the server, then a search engine
could
have that immediately, but if
it's rerpdered on the client,
that's going to be trickier.
That will be the challenge we'll
be discussing today.
One last term, you might
be
wondering what is Google's
searcher called?  We call it
Googlebot, and we'll be
referring to it a lot during
this talk.  I said that a search
crawler is basically a computer
with software running on it.
Well, obviously, maybe in the
'90s
that was the case, but today due
to just the sheer size of the
web, Googlebot is comprised of
thousands of machines running,
you know, all this distributed
software that's constantly
crunching data to understand all
of this continuously expanding
information on the web.
And to be honest, I think
we sometimes take for granted
just how incredible going Search
really is.  For example, I
recently learned with the
knowledge graph, which is a DB
of all the information we have
on the web, it actually maps out
how more than one billion things
in the real world are connected
and over 70 billion facts
between them.  It's kind of
amazing.
Okay.  Well, now that we know
the principles of a search
crawler, let's see how these
three different key steps,
crawling, rendering, and
indexing all connect, because
one crucial thing to understand
is the cycle of how Googlebot
works or how it should ideally
work.  As you can see, we want
these three steps to hand over
to one another instantly, and as
soon as the content is fully
rendered, we want to index it to
keep the Google Search index as
fresh as possible.  This sounds
simple; right?  Well, it would
be if all the content was
rendered on the server and
complete
when we crawl it, but as you
knowsh if a site uses
client-side rendering, that's
not going to be the case, just
like the Angular sample I showed
you earlier.  What does
Googlebot do in this situation?
Well, it includes its own
renderer when it enables to run
to have pages with JavaScript,
but rendering pages at the scale
of the web, requires a lot of
time and computational
resources.
Make no mistake, this is a
serious challenge for search
crawlers, Googlebot
included, so we come to the
important truth about Google
Search we'd like to share today.
Currently the rendering of
JavaScript websites in Google
Search is deferred until
Googlebot has the resources
available to process that
content.
Now, you might be
thinking, okay, well, what does
that really mean?  Well, I'll
show you.  In reality,
Googlebot's process looks a bit
different.
We crawl a page, we fetch the
server side rendered content and
run some initial indexing on
that document.  But rendering
the JavaScript-powered web pages
takes processing power and
memory, and while Googlebot is
very powerful, it doesn't have
infinite resources.  So if the
page has JavaScript in it, the
rendering is actually deferred
until we have the resources
ready to render the client-side
content and then we index the
content further.  So Googlebot
might index a page before
rendering is complete rct and
the final render can actually
arrive several days later.  And
when that final render does
arrive, then we perform another
wave of
offing on that client-side
rendered content.  This means if
your site is using a heavy
amount of client-side JavaScript
for rendering, you can be
tripped up when your content is
being indexed due to the nature
of this two-phase indexing
process.
And so ultimately, what
I'm really trying to say is
because Googlebot actually runs
two ways of indexing across
content, it's possible some
details might be missed.
For example, if your site is a
progressive web application and
you've built it around the
single-page app
model, it's likely all your
unique URLs
share a base of template
resources which are filled in
with contents, and if that's the
case, consider this.  Did the
initially service side
rendered of the page have the
correct canonical tag rendered
in it, because our second wave
of indexing doesn't
check for the Canon ishingts cal
tag at all.  If a user requested
a URL that doesn't exist and you
attempt to use JavaScript to
send the user a 404 page, then
we're actually going to miss
that too.
Now, John and I -- John
will talk more about these
issues later in the talk, but
the important thing to take away
right now is that these really
aren't minor issues , these are
all issues that can affect
your ability, metadata, cal,
HTTP codes.  As I mentioned, at
the beginning of the talk, these
are key to understand the
content on your web pages.
However, just to be
clear, not all web pages on a
website necessarily need to be
indexed.
For example, actually on the
Google I/O schedule website
there is a filtering interface
for the sessions,
and we want search crawlers to
find the individual session
pages, but we discovered the
deep links weren't being
indexed because the cononical
were rendered in the file.
So we implemented a new template
and search side rendered
cononical tags to make sure
they're properly indexed because
we care about that context.  To
ensure these documents were
crawlable, we added them to the
site map as well.
What about the single page app
which allows for filtering
sessions?  That's more of a tool
than a piece of content, right,
therefore, it's not as important
to index the HTML on that page,
so ask yourself this.  Do the
pages I care about from the
perspective of content and
indexing use
client-side rind erring anyway ?
-- rendering anyway?
Okay.  So now you know, when
building a
client-side rendered website you
must tread carefully.  As the
web and industry have gone
bigger, so too have the teams
and companies become more
complex.  We now work in a world
where the people building
websites aren't necessarily the
same people promoting or
marketing those websites, and so
this challenge is one that we're
all facing together as an
industry, both from Google's
perspective and yours as
developers because after all,
you want
your content index by search
engines and so do we.
Well, this seems like a good
opportunity to change tracks,
so, John, do you want to take
over and tell everyone about the
Google Search policy changes and
some of the best practices they
can apply so we can meet this
challenge together?
>> JOHN MUELLER: Sure. Thanks,
Tom.  That was a great summary
of how Search works.  So I still
don't know about those pictures
of spiders.
(Laughter)
Kind of scary, but Googlebot, in
reality, is actually quite
friendly.
Anyway, as Tom mentioned,
indexing of modern
JavaScript-powered websites is a
challenge.  It's a challenge
both for Google as a search
engine and for you all as
developers of the modern way,
and while development on our
side are still ongoing, we'd
like to help you to tackle this
challenge in a more systematic
way, so for that we'll look at
three things here, the policy
change that we mentioned briefly
before, some new tools that are
available to help you diagnose
these issues a little bit
better, and
lastly, a bunch of best
practices to help you to make
better JavaScript-powered
websites that also work well in
Search.
So we've talked about
client-side rendering briefly
and server-side rendering
already.  Client-side rendering
is the traditional state where
JavaScript is processed on the
client.  That would be the
user's browser, or on a search
engine.
For server-side rendering, the
server, so your server, will
process the
JavaScript and serve mostly
static HTML two-search engines.
Also this also has speed
advantages, so especially on
lower-end devices, on mobile
devices, JavaScript can take a
bit of time to run, so this is a
good practice.
For both of these, we index the
state
as ultimately seen in the
browser, so that's what we pick
up, and we try to render pages
when we need to do that.
There's a third type of
rendering that we've talked
about in the past.
It starts in the same way in
that prerendered HTML is sent to
the client, so you have the same
speed advantages there; however,
on interaction or after the
initial page load, the server
adds JavaScript on top of that,
and as with server-side
rendering, our job as a search
engine is pretty easy here.
We just pick up the prerendered
HTML content.  We call this
hybrid rendering.
This is actually our long-term
recommendation.  We think this
is probably where things will
end up in the long run; however,
in practice, implementing this
can still be a bit tricky, and
most frameworks don't make this
easy.
A quick call out to Angular,
since we featured them in the
beginning as an example of a
page that was hard to pick up.
They have built a hybrid
rendering mode with Angular
Universal that helps you to do
this a little bit easier.  Over
time, I imagine more frameworks
will have something similar to
make it easier for you to do
this in practice; however, at
least at the moment, if your
server isn't writ number
JavaScript, you're going to be
dealing with kind of double
maintenance of controlling and
templating logic as well, so
what's another option?  What's
another way that JavaScript
sites could work well with
Search?
We have another option
that we'd like to introduce.  We
call it Dynamic Rendering.
In a nutshell, dynamic rendering
is the principle of sending
normal client-side rendered
content to users
and sending fully server-side
rendered content to search
engines and to other crawlers
that need it.  This is the
policy change that we
talked about before, so we call
it dynamic because your site
dynamically detects whether or
not the requester is
a search engine crawler, like
Googlebot, and only then sends a
server-side rendered content
directly to the client.  You can
include other web services here
as well that can't deal with
rendering.  For example, maybe
social media
services or chat services,
anything that tries to extract
structured information to your
pages, and for all other
requesters, so your normal
users, you would serve your
normal hybrid or client-side
rendered code.  This also gives
you the best of both
worlds and makes it easy for to
you migrate to hybrid rendering
for your users over time as
well.
One thing to note, this is not a
requirement for JavaScript sites
to be indexed.
As you'll see later, Googlebot
can render most pages already.
For dynamic rendering, our
recommendation is to add a new
tool or
step in your server
infrastructure to act as a
dynamic renderer.
This reads your normal
client-side content and sends a
prerendered version
to crawlers, so how might you
implement that.  We have two
options here that help you to
kind of get started.
The first is Puppeteer, which is
a no
JavaScript library, which wraps
Google Chrome underneath.  This
allows you to render pages on
your own.
Another option is Rendertron,
which renders on your side as
well.  Both are Open Source, so
you could make your own version
or use something from a third
party that does something
similar as well.  For more
information on these, I'd
recommend checking the I/O
session on Headless Chrome.  I
believe there's a recording
about that already.
Either way, keep in mind
rendering can be pretty resource
intensive, so we recommend doing
this out of band from your
normal web server and
implementing caching as you need
it.
So let's take a quick
look at what your server
infrastructure might
look like with a dynamic
renderer integrated.  Requests
from Googlebot come in on the
side here.  They're sent to your
normal server, and then, perhaps
through a reverse
proxy, they're sent to the
dynamic renderer.  There it
requests and renders a complete
final page and sends that back
to the search engines, so
without needing to implement --
maintain any new code, this
setup could enable a website
that's designed only for
client-side rendering to perform
dynamic rendering
of the content to Googlebot and
to other appropriate clients.
If you think about it,
this kind of solves the problems
that Tom mentioned before, and
now we can be kind of confident
that the important content of
our web pages is available to
Googlebot when it performs its
initial wave of indexing.  So
how might you recognize
Googlebot requests?
This is actually pretty easy.
So the easiest way to do that is
to find Googlebot in the user
agent stream.  You can do
something similar for other
services that you want to serve
prerendered content to, and for
Googlebot as well as some
others, you can also do a
reverse DNS lookup if you
want to be sure that you're
serving it just to legitimate
clients.
One thing to kind of
watch out
for here is that if you serve
adapted content to smartphone
users vs.
desktop users or you you
redirect users to different URLs
depending on the device that
they use, you must make sure
that dynamic rendering returns
device
rendered content; in other words
, mobile users when they go to
your page should see the mobile
version, and the others should
see the desktop version.  If
you're using responsive design,
if you're using the same HTML
and using CSS to conditionally
change the way the content is
shown to users,  this is one
thing you don't need to watch
out for because the HTML is
exactly the same.
What's not immediately
clear from the user agents is
that Googlebot is
currently using a somewhat older
browser to render pages.
It uses Chrome 41, which was
released in 2015.  The most
visible implication for
developers is that newer
JavaScript versions or coding
conventions like arrow functions
aren't supported by Googlebot,
and with that, also any API that
was added after Chrome 41
currently isn't supported.
You can check these on a site
like Can I Use, and while you
could theoretically install an
older version of Chrome, we
don't recommend doing that for
obvious security reasons.
Additionally, there's some APIs
that Googlebot doesn't support
because they don't provide
additional value for Search.
We'll check these out too.  Much
All right.  So you might
be thinking this sounds like a
lot of work, John.  I don't
know.  Do I really need to do
this?
So a lot of times Googlebot can
render pages properly.  Why do I
really have to watch out for
this?  Well, there are a few
reasons to watch out for this.
First is if your site is large
and rapidly changing.  For
example, if you have a news
website that has a lot of new
content that keeps coming out
regularly and
requires quick indexing, as Tom
showed,
rendering is deferred from
indexing, so if you have a large
dynamic website, then kind of
the new content might take a
while to be indexed otherwise.
Secondly, if you rely on
modern JavaScript functionality,
for example,
if you have any libraries that
can't be
transspiled back to ES5, then
dynamic rendering can help you
there, and that said, we
continue to recommend using
proper graceful degradation
techniques so that even older
clients have access to your
content.
And finally, there's a third
reason to also look into this,
in particular, if you're using
social media
sites, if your site relies on
sharing through social media or
through chat applications.
If these services require access
to your page's content, then
dynamic
rendering can help you there too
.
So when might you not use
dynamic rendering?  I think the
main aspect here is balancing
the time and effort needed to
implement and to run this with
the games that are received, so
remember, implementation and
maintenance of dynamic rendering
can use a significant amount of
server resources, and if you see
Googlebot is able to index your
pages properly, then if you're
not
making critical, high-frequency
changes to your site, maybe you
don't actually need to implement
anything special.
Most sites smud be able to let
Googlebot render their -- should
be able to let Googlebot render
your pages just fine.
Like I mentioned, if
Googlebot can render your pages,
you probably don't need dynamic
rendering for your site.  Let's
look at a few tools to help you
figure out what the situation
is.
When diagnosing rendering, we
recommend doing so
incrementally, first checking
the HTTP raw response and
checking the rendered version,
either on mobile or mobile and
desktop, if you serve different
content, for example.  Let's
take a quick look at these.
So looking at the raw cononical
raw HTTP response, one is to
gain access to Google Search
ConSol.
To look at the features, you
need to verify ownership of your
website.  This is easy to do.
There are a ways to do that.  I
would recommend you do that
regardless of what you work on.
Once you have it verified, you
can use a tool called Fetch as
Google, and it
will show the HTTP response
rendered by Googlebot, including
the response code on top and the
HTML that was provided before
any rendering was done.  This is
a great way to double-check what
is happening on your server,
especially if you're using
dynamic rendering to serve
different content to Googlebot.
Once you've checked the
raw
response, I recommend checking
how the pages actually render,
so the tool I use for this is
the mobile-friendly test.  It's
a really fast way of checking
Google's rendering of a page.
As I mentioned, the name
suggests that it's made for
mobile devices, so as you might
know, over time our indexing
will be primarily focused on the
mobile version of a page.
We call this mobile first
indexing, so it's good to
already start focusing on the
mobile version when you're
testing rendering.
We recommend testing a
few pages of each kind of page
within your website, so, for
example, if you have an
eCommerce site, check the Home
Panel, some of the category
pages, and some -- Page, some of
the category pages, and some of
the details pages.  You don't
have to check all the pages,
because a lot of times the
template will be similar.  If
your pages render here, chances
are high that Googlebot can
render your pages for Search as
well.
One thing that's kind of a down
side here is you just see the
screenshot.  You don't see the
rendered HTML here.  What's one
way to check the HTML?
Well, new for I/O, I think we
launched
this yesterday, we've added a
way to review the HTML after
rendering.
This is also in the
mobile-friendly test.  It shows
you what was created after
rendering with the mobile
Googlebot, includes all of the
mark-up for links, for images,
for structure data, any
invisible elements that might be
on the page after rendering.
So what do you do if the
page just doesn't render
properly at all?
We also just launched a way to
get full information about
loading issues from a page as
well.  On this part within the
mobile-friendly test, you can
see all of the resources that
were blocked by Googlebot, so
this could be JavaScript files
or API responses.
A lot of times not everything
needs to be crawled, kind of
like Tom mentioned.
For example, also, if you have
tracking pixels on a page,
Googlebot doesn't really need to
render those tracking pixels,
but if you use an API to pull in
content from somewhere else
and that API endpoint is blocked
by robot text, then obviously we
can't pull in that content at
all.  An aggregate list of all
of these
issues is also available in
Search console.
So when they fail in a browser,
I check the developer console
for more information to see more
details on
exceptions, and new for I/O, one
of the most requested features
from people who make
JavaScript-powered sites for
Search
is also showing the console rr
log when Google tries to render
something.  This allows you to
check for JavaScript issues, for
example, if
you're using ES6 or have other
issues with the JavaScript when
it tries to run.  This makes my
life so much easier because I
don't have to help people with
all of these detailed rendering
issues that much.
Desktop is also a topic
that still comes up.  As you've
seen in maybe some of the other
sessions, desktop isn't quite
dead, so you can run all of
these diagnostics in the rich
results test as well.  This tool
shows the desktop version of
these pages .
So now that we've seen
how to diagnose issues, what
kind of issues have we run
across with modern
JavaScript-powered science?
What patterns do you need to
watch out for and handle well on
your side?
So remember Tom mentioned at the
beginning of the talk something
about lazy loading images and
being unsure if they're
indexable?  Well, it turns out
they're only sometimes
indexable, so it was good to
look at that.  Depending on how
lazy loading is implemented,
Googlebot may be able to trigger
it, and with that, may be able
to pick up images for indexing.
For example, if the images are
above
the fold and you're lazy loading
-- your lazy loading kind of
runs those images automatically,
Googlebot will probably see
that; however, if you want to be
sure that Googlebot is able to
pick up lazy loaded images, one
way to do that
is to use a no script tag, so
you can add a no script tag
around a normal image element,
and we'll be able to pick that
up for image search directly.
Another approach is to
use structured data on a page.
When we see structured data that
refers to an image, we can also
pick that up for image search.
As a side note for images, we
don't index images that are
referenced only through CSS.  We
currently only index images that
are kind of embedded with with
the structured data mark-up or
with image tags .
Apart from lazy-loaded
images, there are other types of
content that require some kind
of interaction to be loaded.
What about tabs that load the
content after you click on them
or if you have infinite scroll
patterns on a site?  Googlebot
generally won't interact with a
page, so it wouldn't be able to
see these.
There are two ways that you can
get this too Googlebot, though.
Either you can preload the
content and
just use CSS to toggle
visibility on and off.  That way
Googlebot can see that content
from the preloaded version.  Or
alternately, you can just use
separate URLs and navigate the
user and Googlebot to those
pages individually.
Now, Googlebot is a patient bot,
but there are a lot of pages
that we have to crawl, so we
have to be efficient and kind of
go through pages fairly quickly.
When pages are slow to load or
render, Googlebot might miss
some of the rendered content,
and since embedded
resources are aggressively
cached for search, rendering
time outs are really hard to
test for, so to limit these
problems, we recommend making
performant
and efficient web pages, which
you're hopefully already doing
for users anyway; right?  Limit
the number of embedded resources
and avoid artificial delays like
timed interstitials like here.
You can test pages with the
usual set of tools and roughly
test rendering with a
mobile-friendly testing tool.
And while time-outs here are a
little different for indexing,
in general, if the pages work in
the mobile-friendly test,
they'll work for search indexing
too .
Additionally, Googlebot wants to
see the page as a new user would
see it,
so we crawl and render pages in
a stateless way.  Any API that
tries to store something locally
would not be supported, so if
you use any of these
technologies, make
sure to use graceful degradation
techniques to allow anyone to
view your pages, even if these
APIs are not supported .
And that was it with regards to
critical best practices.  Now
it's time to take a quick circle
back and see what we've seen.
So first, we recommend
checking for proper
implementation of best practices
that we talked about, in
particular lazy-loaded images
are really common.  Second, test
a sample of your pages with the
mobile-friendly test and use the
other testing tools as well.
Remember, you don't need to test
all of your pages, just make
sure that you have all of the
templates covered.
And then finally, if pages are
large and -- if sites are large
and quick-changing and you -- or
you can't reasonably fix
rendering across the site, then
maybe consider using dynamic
rendering techniques to serve
Googlebot and other crawlers a
prerendered version of your
page.
And finally, if you do decide to
use dynamic rendering, make sure
to double-check the results
there as well.
One thing to keep in mind,
indexing isn't the same as
ranking, but generally speaking,
pages do need to be
indexed before their content can
appear in Search at all.
I don't know, Tom, do you think
that covers about everything?
>> TOM GREENAWAY: Well,
it was a lot to take in, John.
That was some amazing content.
But I guess one question I have,
and I think maybe other people
in the audience have this on
their mind as well, is, is it
always going to be this way,
John?
>> JOHN MUELLER: That's a
great question, Tomment I don't
know.  Is -- I think -- Tom.  I
don't know.  I think things will
never stay the same.  As you
mentioned in the beginning, this
is challenge for us.  That's
important.  Within Google
Search, we want our search
results to reflect the web as it
is regardless of the type of
website that's used, so our
long-term version is that you,
the developers, shouldn't need
to worry as much about this for
search crawlers.
So circling back on the diagram
that Tom showed in the beginning
with deferred rendering, one
change we want
to make is to move rendering
closer to crawling and indexing.
Another change we want to
make is to make Googlebot use a
more modern version of Chrome
over time.  Both of these will
take a bit of time.  I don't
like making long-term
predictions, but I suspect it'll
be at least untilend of year
until this works a little bit.
Similarly, we trust that
rendering will be more and more
common across all kinds of web
services.
So at that point, dynamic
rendering is probably less
critical for modern science;
however, the best practices that
we talked about, they'll
continue to be important here as
well.
How does that sound, Tom?
>> TOM GREENAWAY: That
sounds really great.  I think
that covers everything, and I
hope everyone in the room has
learned some new approaches and
tools that are useful for making
your modern JavaScript-powered
websites work well in Google
Search.  If you have any
questions, we'll be in the
mobile web sandbox area together
with the Search Console team,
and alternatively you can reach
out to us
online be it through Twitter,
our live office hours Hangouts
and in the webmaster help forum
as well, so thanks, everyone,
for your time.
>> JOHN MUELLER: Thank
you.
(Applause)
RAW FILE
GOOGLE I/O 2018
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 10, 2018
STAGE 2
9:30 AM
THE FUTURE OF COMPUTING WITH
: A CONVERSATION WITH JOHN
HENNESSY
T6813B
Services Provided By:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
1 877 825 5234
+001 719 481 9835
www.captionfirst.com
***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.  This text,
document, or file is not to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
***
GOOGLE I/O 2018
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 10, 2018
9:30 AM
STAGE 2
THE FUTURE OF COMPUTING: A
CONVERSATION WITH JOHN HENNESSY
T
6813B
>> What I find fascinating about
technology and engineering is
there's always something new
happening.  It's a field that
goes out into the world.
>> If you know computer
temperature and technology
business, you know the name John
Hennessy.
>> John Hennessy joined Stanford
University launching a life long
commitment to technology and
education.  He was instrumental
in the development
of a new technology known as
reduced instruction set
computer, a game changer in
computing that increased
performance while reducing
costs.  He founded a start-up
and helped transfer risk to the
commercial market.
>> For me, entrepreneurship is
about
transforming things by taking
new ideas, seeing them from
conference into practice.
>> In 2000, he was named the
tenth president of Stanford
University.
>> John Hennessy is a world
class scholar, on the boards of
lots of very successful
ventures, and the recipient of
numerous awards.
>> I've sometimes had to put
myself in situation that's had
some uncertainty about how they
were going to evolve over time
but it's provided me with an
opportunity to grow and learn
and experience new things, which
I think is one of life's great
rewards.
(applause)
>> JOHN HENNESSY: Morning.
Morning, everyone.
(applause)
Boy, I'm delighted to be here
today, and have a chance to talk
to you about what is one of the
biggest challenges we've
faced in computing in 40 years,
but also, a tremendous
opportunity to rethink how we
build computers and how we move
forward.  You know, there's been
a lot of discussion about the
ending of Moore's Law.  The
first thing to remember about
the ending of Moore's Law is
something Gordon Moore said to
me.
He said, all exponentials come
to an end.  It's just a question
of when, and
that's what's happening with
Moore's Law
.  If we look at, what does it
really mean to say Moore's Law
is ending?  What does it mean?
Well, look what's happening in
DRAMs, that's probably a good
place to start because with all
depend on the incredible growth
and memory capacity.  And if you
look at what's happening in
DRAMs, for many years we were
achieving increases of about 50
percent, in other words, going
up slightly faster even than
Moore's Law, then we began a
period of slow down and if you
look at what's happened in the
last ten years, this technology
we were used to seeing boom, the
number of mega bits per chip,
more than doubling every two
years is now going up at about
10 percent aee and is going to
take about seven years to
double.
Now, DRAMs are particularly odd
technology because they used
deep
trenched capacitors so they
require a particular fabrication
technology.  What's happening in
processors, though?
If you look at the data in
processors, you'll see a similar
slow down.  Moore's Law is that
red line going up
there on a nice log rhythmic
plot.  Notice the blue line.
That's a particular Intel
microprocessor at that date.
It begins
diverging, slowly at first, but
look at the last ten years.  The
gap has grown.  In fact, if you
look at where we are in 2015,
2016, we're more than a factor
of ten off had we stayed on that
Moore's line curve.
Now, the thing to remember is
that it also, there's also a
cost factor in here.
Fabs are getting a lot more
expensive and the cost of chips
is actually not going down as
fast so a result of that is that
the cost for transistor is
actually increasing at a worse
rate.  So, we're beginning to
see the effects of that as we
think about archtecture.
But, if the slowdown
of Moore's Law, which you see
all the press about, the big
issue is the end of what we call
Dennard's scaling.  So, Bob
Dennard, an IBM employee, the
guy who invested the one
transistor DRAM and he made a
prediction many years ago that
the energy, the power per square
millimeter of silicone would
stay
constant, would stay constant
because
voltage levels would come down,
capac itants would come down.
What does that mean?  If the
energy stays constant and the
number of transistor increases
exponentially then the energy
per
transistor is actually going
down and in terms of energy
consumption and cheaper and
cheaper to computes.
Well, what happened with
Dennard's scaling?  Look at that
red line.
The red line shows you
technology
improving on a standard
Dennard's law curve the the blue
line is what's happening to
power.  You've seen Microsoft's
processor now.  They slow their
clock down, turn off cores, do
all kinds of things because
otherwise they're going to burn
up.  I mean, I never thought
we'd see the day where a
processor would actually slow
itself down to prevent itself
overheating but we're there so
what happens with Dennard's
scaling is the
last, it began to slow down
starting
about 97, and then since 2007,
it's essentially halted.  The
result is a big change.  All of
a sudden, energy, power becomes
the key limiter.  Not the number
of transistors
available to designers, but the
will
their power consumption becomes
the key limiter.
That requires you to think
completely
dimply about archtecture, about
how you
design machines.
It means inconsistency in how an
architecture computes is
penalized much more heavily than
it was in this earlier time.
And of course, guess what.  All
the devices we carry around, all
the devices we use are running
off batteries.  So, all of a
sudden, energy is a critical
resource, right?  What's the
worst thing that happens?  Your
cell phone runs out of power,
your smartphone runs out of
power, that's a disaster, right?
But you think about all the
devices we walk around with.
They're hooked up to battery.
Think about the era, the coming
era of IoT where we're going to
have devices always on and
permanently on which are
expected to last ten years on
a single battery by using energy
harvesting  techniques.  Energy
becomes the key resource in
making those things work
efficiently.  And as we move
more and more to always
on devices with things like
Google Assistant you're going to
want your device or at least the
CPU on all the time if not the
screen so we're going to have to
worry more and more about power.
But the surprising thing that
many
people are surprised by is that
energy efficiency is a giant
issue in large Cloud
configurations.  This shows you
what the typical capital cost
would be like for a Google data
center.
You'll notice that green slice
there, those are the servers,
but look at the size of that red
slice.  That red slice is the
cost of the power plus cooling
infrastructure.
You're spending as much on power
and cooling as you're spending
on processors
so energy efficiency become
becomes a really critical issue
as we go forward and the end of
Dennard's scaling has meant
there's no more free lunch.  For
a lot of years, we had a free
lunch.  It was pretty easy to
figure out how to make
computation more energy
efficient.  Now, it's a lot
harder.
And you can see the impact of
this
this just shows you 40 years of
processor performance, single
and multicomponent.  So at the
beginning of the microprocessor
era, we were seeing about 22
percent improvement per yearment
of
the creation of risk in the
mid-1980s, a dramatic use of
instruction level parallels and
pipelining, multiple issue.
We saw this incredible period of
about 20 years where we got
roughly 50 percent performance
improvement per year.  50
percent.  That was amazing.
Then, the beginning of the end
of Dennard's scaling.  That
cause ever caused everybody to
move to multicore.  What did
multicore do?  Mulletsy core
shoved the efficiency problem
from the hardware designer to
the software people.  Now the
software people had to figure
out who to use those  multicore
processors efficiently.
But, Amdel's law came along,
reared its ugly head.  I'll show
you some data on that.  And now
we're in this late stage period
where it looks like we're
getting about 3 percent
performance improvement per
year.  Doubling could take 20
years.  That's the end of the
general purpose processor
performance as we know it, as
we're used to for so many years
.  Why did this happen?
Why did it grind to a halt so
fast?
Well, think about what's
happening where we're building
these deep pipeline machines.
Fifteen, 16, 17 stages.  Four
issues per clock.  That machine
needs to have 60 instructions
that it's working on at once, 60
instructions.  How does it
possibly get 60 instructions?
It uses speculation.
It guesses about branches.
It yanks instructions and tries
to execute them.  But guess what
happens?  Nobody can predict
branches perfectly.  Every time
you predict a branch
incorrectly, you have to undo
all the work associated with
that misprediction.
You've got to back it out, rue
store the state of the machine.
And if you look inside a typical
Intel
Core i7 today, on integer code,
roughly 25 percent of the
instructions that get executed
end up being thrown away.
Guess what?  The energy still
got burnt to execute
all these instructions
.  And then I threw the results
away and had to restore the
state of the machine.  A lot of
wasted energy.  That's why we
saw the single core processor
go.
Amdahl's law, more than 30 years
ago, it's still true today.
Even if you take large data
centers with heavily parallelled
workloads, it's very hard to
write a big complicated piece of
software and not have small
sections of it be sequential,
whether it's synchronization or
coordination or something else.
So, think about what happens.
You get a 64-processor multicore
in the future.  Suppose 1
percent, just 1 percent of the
code is sequential.
Then that 64-processor multicore
only runs at the speed of a
40-processor core.  But, guess
what?
You paid all the energy for a
64-processor core all the time
and you only got 40 processors
out of that.  Slightly more than
half.  That's the problem.
We've got to break through this
efficiency barrier.  We've got
to rethink how we design
machines.  So, what's left?
Well, software centric
approaches.  Can we make our
machines -- can we make our
systems more efficient?
It's great that we have these
modern scripting languages,
they're interpreted, they
encourage reuse.  They've really
liberated programmers to get a
lot more code written and create
incredible functionality.
They're efficient for
programmers.  They're very
inefficient for execution and
I'll show you that in a second.
And then there are hardware
centric approaches, what Dave
Patterson and I call
domain-specific architectures.
Namely, designing an
architecture which isn't fully
general purpose but which does a
set of domains, a set of
applications really well.  Much
more efficiently.
So, let's take a look at what
the opportunity is.
This is a chart that comes out
of a
paper by Charles Licensen and a
group of colleagues at MIT
called, there's plenty of room
at the talk.
They take matrix multiply, they
write it in python, they run it
on an 18-core Intel processor
and then they proceed to
optimize it.  First, rewrite it
in C.  That speeds it up 47
times.  Now, any compiler in the
world that can get a speed-up of
47 would be really remarkable,
even a speed-up of 20.  Then
they rewrite it with parallel
loops.  They get almost a factor
of nine out of that.  Then they
rewrite it by doing memory
optimize conversation.  That
gives them a factor of 20.  They
block the matrix.  They allocate
it to the caches properly.  That
gives them a factor of 20.  And
then,  finally, they rewrite it
using Intel AVX instructions,
using the vector instructions in
the Intel core, right?
Domain-specific instructions
that do vector operations
efficiently, that gives them
another factor of ten.  The end
result is that final version
runs 62,000 times faster than
the initial version.
Now, admittedly matrix multiply
is an easy case small piece of
code but it shows the potential
of rethinking how we write this
software and making it better.
So what about
these domain-specific
architectures, really, what
we're going to try to do is
make a breakthrough in how we
build the hardware and by
domain-specific we're referring
to a class of processors which
do a range of  applications.
They're not like, for example,
the
modem inside your cell phone.
That's programmed once, never
does anything else.  But think
of a set of processors which do
eye range of applications
related to a particular
application.  They're useful in
that domain.  They take
advantage of specific knowledge
about that domain when they run
so they can run much more
efficiently.  Obvious  examples,
doing things for neural network
processors.  Doing thing that's
focus on machine learning.  One
example.  GPUs are another
example of this kind of
thinking, right?
They're programmable in the
context of doing graphics
processing.  So any of you who
have ever seen any of the books
that Dave Patterson and I wrote.
You know that you want
quantitative approaches and we
like to analyze why
things work so the key about
domain specific architecture is
there is no black magic here.
Going to a more limited range of
architectures doesn't
automatically make things
faster.  We have to make some
specific
architectural changes that win
.  The first one is parallelism.
We go from a multicore to a
single multisystem data so
instead of having each one of my
cores fetch separate instruction
streams, that separate set of
caches, I've got one set of
instructions going to a whole
set of functional units.  It's
much more efficient.  What do I
give up?  I give up flexibility
when I do that.  I absolutely
give up flexibility but
the efficiency gain is dramatic
.  Something like VLW that uses
a set of operations where the
compiler has decided that a set
of operations can occur in
parallel so I shift work from
runtime to compile time.  Again,
it's less flexible but for
applications when it works, it's
much more efficient.
I move away from caches.  So,
caches are one of the great
interventions of computer
science, one of the truly great
interventions.  The problem is
with when there's low space,
caches don't work.  They
actually slow programs down.
They slow them down.  So, we
move away from that to user
control local memories.
What's the trade-off?  Now
somebody has to figure out how
to map their applications in a a
user-controlled memory
structure.  Cache does it
automatically for you.  It's
very general purpose but for
certain applications I can do a
lot better by mapping those
things myself.
And then finally, I focus on
only the amount of accuracy I
need.
I move from IEEE to the lower
precision floating point or from
32 and
64-bit integers to eight-bit and
16-bit integers.  If that's all
the accuracy I need, I can do
eight eight-bit operations
notice
same amount of time I can do one
64-bit operation, so
considerably faster.  But, to go
along with that, I also need a
domain-specific language.
I need a language that will
match up to that specific
hardware.  We're not going to be
able to take code in pager and
extract the kind of information
we need to map to a specific
architecture.  We've got to
rethink how we program these
machines and that's going to be
high level operations.
It's going to be vector vector
multiplier or vector matrix
multiplier or sparse matrix
organization so that I get that
high level information that I
need and I can compile that down
into the architecture.
The key in doing these
domain-specific
languages will be
to retain enough machine
independence that I don't have
to recode things, that a
compiler can come along, take a
domain-specific language, map it
to maybe one architecture
running in the
Cloud, maybe another
architecture that's running on
my smartphone.  That's going to
be the challenge.
Ideas like TensorFlow and OpenGL
are a step in this direction,
but it's really new space.
We're just beginning to
understand it and understand how
to design in this space
.  You know, I built my first
computer almost 50 years ago,
believe it or not.  I've seen a
lot of revolutions in this
incredible IT industry since
then.  The creation of the
internet.  The creation of the
worldwide web.
The manualic of the
microprocessor, a
smartphone, personal computers.
But the one I think that is
really going to change our lives
is the break through in machine
learning and artificial
intelligence.
This is a technology which
people have worked on for 50
years and finally,
finally, we made the break
through
.  And the basis of that break
through?  We needed about a
million more times than we
thought we needed to get the
technology to work but we
finally got to
the point where could apply that
kind of computer power.
And the one thing that shows
there's one thing growing just
as fast as Moore's Law, the
number of papers being published
in machine learning.
It is a revolution.  It's going
to change our world and I'm
sure some of you saw the duplex
demo the other day.  In the
domain of making appointments,
it passes the
Turing test in that domain which
is extraordinary.  It doesn't
pass it in general terms but it
passes it in the domain and
that's really an indication of
what's coming.
So, how do you think about
building a
domain-specific architecture to
do deep neural networks.  This
is a big picture of what's
inside a Tensor processing unit.
The point I want to make is if
you look at what uses up the
silicone area, notice it's not
used for a lot of control.  It's
not used for a lot of caching.
It's used to do things that are
directly relevant to the
computation.
So, this processor do 256 by
256.
That is 64,000 multiply
accumulates, eight-bit multiply
accumulates every single clock.
Every single clock
so really interesting things,
enormous amount of
computational capability.
You're not going to run general
C code
on this
.  So what we've plotted here is
performance per watt and you can
see
that the first generation gets
30 times per watt compared to a
general purpose processor.  It
even does considerably better
than
a GPU largely by switching from
floating point to lower density
energy, which is much faster.
So, again, this notion of
tailoring the architecture to
the specific domain
becomes really crucial.
So, this is a new era.  In some
sense, it's a return to the
past.  In the early days of
computing, as
computers were just being
developed, we often had teams of
people working together.  We had
people who were early
applications experts working
with people who were doing the
beginning of the software
environment, building the first
compilers and the first software
environment and people doing the
architecture
and they're working as a
vertical team.  That kind of
integration where we get a
design team to go from
replication of some specific
language to architecture and can
think about how to rebuild
machines in new ways to get
this.  It's an enormous
opportunity and it's a new kind
of challenge for the industry
to go forward
but I think there are enough
interesting applications where
we can get incredible advantages
by tailoring our machine in new
ways and I think if we can do
that maybe we'll free up some
time to worry about another
problem, namely cybersecurity
and whether or not the hardware
designers can finally help the
software designers to improve
the security of our system, and
that would be a great problem to
focus on.  Thank you for your
attention and I'm happy to
answer any questions you might
have
(applause)
Thanks.
Okay. Who's got a question?  You
can ask me anything.  I've done
this a lot.
No questions?
>> Hi.
Can you talk about some of the
advantages in quantum and
neomorphic computing?
>> JOHN HENNESSY: Yeah, so
quantum, that's a really good
question.  My view is that we've
got to build a bridge from where
we are today to post silicone.
The possibilities for post
silicone, the two big, there are
a couple.  I mean, there's
organic, there's quantum,
there's carbon nano fiber,
there's a few different
possibilities out there
[N][F][N] the reason being, that
might take you a thousand
cubits.  Bit computational power
for things
that make sense, protein folder,
cryptography of 128 bit cubit is
phenomenal so we could get an
enormous jump forward there.  We
need something post silicone.
We need something post silicone.
Maybe as Moore's Law slows down,
maybe another decade or so
before it comes to a real halt
and we've got to get an
alternative technology out there
because I think there's lots of
creative software to be written
that wants to run on faster
machines.
>> At the end of your
presentation, you briefly
mentioned how we could start
using hardware to increase
security.  Would you mind
elaborating?
>> JOHN HENNESSY: Sure. So
here's my view of security.
Everybody knows about meltdown
and specter.  The efficiency
thing to understand what
happened is an attack that
basically undermined
architecture in a
way that we
.  I worked on that since the
mid 1990s and we didn't even
know it.  Programs run, I don't
fell telo how fast they run.
All I tell you is what the right
answer is.  Side channel attacks
that use performance to leak
information basically go around
our definition of architecture
so we need to rethink about
architecture.
You know, in the 1960s and
1970s, there was a lot of
thought about how to do a better
job of protection.  Rings and
domains and capabilities.  They
all got dropped and they got
dropped because two things.
First of all, we became
convinced that people were going
to verify their software and it
was always going to be perfect.
well the problem is the amount
of software we write is far
bigger than the aments of
software we verify, so that's
not going to help.
[N][F][N]
I think it's time for software
accurate protects to think
about, how can they build
systems to ensure the right
support?  How do we build those?
How do we make sure they build
systems effectively and how do
we work together to create a
more secure environment and I
think it's going to mean
thinking back on some of those
old ideas and bring them back in
some cases.
>> After I took my processor
architecture class which used
your book --
>> JOHN HENNESSY: I hope it
didn't hurt you.
(laughter)
>> Hopefully not. I had a real
appreciation for the simplicity
of a risk system.
It seems like we've gone towards
more complexity with
domain-specific languages and
things.  Is that just because of
performance or has your
philosophy changes?  What do you
think?
>> JOHN HENNESSY: No, I actually
think
they're not necessarily
more complicated.  They have a
narrower range of applicability.
But they're not more
applicabilitied in the sense
that they're a better match for
what the application is.  The
key thing is we weren't
targeting people writing
assembly language anymore.  That
was the old way of doing things,
right?  In the 1980s, the move
was on.  Unix was the first
operating system ever written in
a high level language.  The
first ever.  The move was on
from assembly language to high
level languages and what you
needed to target was the
compiler output so it's the same
thing here.
You're targeting the output of a
domain-specific language that
works well for a range of
domains and you design the
architecture to match that
environment.  Make it as simple
as possible, but no simpler.
>> With the domain-specific
architectures, do you have
examples of
what might be the most promising
areas
for future domain-specific
architectures?
>> JOHN HENNESSY: So I this I
the most obvious ones are things
related to machine learning,
computations both training as
well as inference, so that's one
big field.
Virtual reality
, if we really want to construct
well
made augmented reality, it's a
complex structure.
They're going to give us a list
on some of the most
computationally intensive
problems.  We're still going to
have to advance and think about
how to push forward
general purpose because the
general purpose machines are
going to drive these domain
specific machines.  The domain
specific machine will not do
everything for us so we're going
to have to figure out ways to go
forward on that front as well.
>> How do you think about some
emerging memory technology?  How
will it impact the future of
computer architecture?  Thank
you.
>> JOHN HENNESSY: That's a
really great question.
So, as we get to the end of
DRAMs, I think some of the more
innovative memory technologies
are beginning to appear.
So-called phase change
technologies which had the
advantage that they can probably
scale better than DRAM, and
probably even better than flash
technologies.  They have the
advantage that lifetimes are
better, too, than flash.
The problem with flash is it
runs out.
Some of these phase chain or mem
risk technologies have the
ability to scale longer and what
you'll get is probably not a
replacement for DRAM.  You'll
probably get a replacement for
flash and a replacement for
disks and I think that
technology is coming very fast,
and it will change the way we
think about memory hierarchies
and I/O hierarchy because you'll
have a device that's not quite
as fast as DRAM but a
lot faster than the other
alternatives and that will
change the way we want to build
machines.
>> As a person, you think about
education quite often.
We all saw Zuckerberg having a
conversation with
Congress, and I'm excited to see
children getting general
education around computing and
coding which is
something that a lot of us
didn't have the opportunity to
have.  Where do you see
education, not only
for K12 grad, post-grad, et
cetera, but
also existing people in
policy-making decisions, et
cetera?
>> JOHN HENNESSY: Well, I think
first of all, education has
become a life-long endeavor.
Nobody has one job for a
lifetime anymore.  They change
what they're doing, and
education becomes constant.  I
mean, you think about the stuff
you learned as an undergrad and
you think about how far, how
much technology has already
changed, right?  So we have to
do more there.
I think we also have to make
more, technology, society needs
to be more technology-savvy.
Computing is changing every
single part of the world we live
in.
To not have some understanding I
think limits your ability to
lead an organization, to make
decisions.  So we're going to
have to educate our young people
at beginning and we're going to
have to make an investment in
education so that as people's
careers change over their
lifetime they can go
back and engage in education
.  Not necessarily going back to
college, but it's going to have
to be engaging, something that
works well for people.
>> Hi, from BBC, just wondered
what your view was on the amount
of energy being
used on bitcoin mining and other
crypts owe currencies and that
sort of thing.
>> JOHN HENNESSY: Yeah, sure. I
could build a special purpose
architecture to mine.s.  That's
another obvious example of a
domain specific architecture for
sure.
So,
I'm a long term believer in
cryptocurrency as an important
part of my space and what we're
going to have to do is figure
out how to make it work,
how to make it work efficiently,
how to make it work seamlessly,
how to make it work
inexpensively.  I think those
are all problems that can be
conquered an I think you'll see
a
bunch of people that have both
the
algorithmic heft and the ability
to rethink how we do that, and
really make cryptocurrencies go
quite quick and then we can also
build machines which accelerate
that even further.  A
cryptocurrency transaction
should be
faster than a cash transaction,
and certainly no slower than a
credit card transaction.  We're
not there yet, but we could get
there with enough work and I
think that's where we ought to
be moving to.
>> What do you think bets
the future of operating system
has to have.
>> JOHN HENNESSY: So I think
operating systems are really
crucial.  Way back when in the
1980s we thought
we were going to solve all our
operating
system problems by going to
kernel based operating systems
and the kernel would be this
really small thing that just did
the core of protection and
memory management and then
everything else around it would
be protected, basically.  And
what happened was kernel started
out really small and then they
got bigger and then they got
bigger and then they got bigger
and all of a sudden almost the
entire operating system was
in the kernel, primarily to make
it performance-efficient.
And the same thing happened with
hyper visors.  They started
really small in the beginning
and got bigger.  We're going to
have to figure out how we
structure complex operating
systems so they can deal with
the protection issues, they can
deal with efficiency issues,
they can work well.  We should
be building operating systems
which, from the beginning,
realize that they're going to
run on large numbers of
processors and organize them in
such a way that they can do that
efficiently because that's the
future.  We're going to have to
rely on that.
>> In your intro video you
mentioned this chasm between
concept and practice and also in
your talk you've mentioned that
hardware is vital to the future
of computing.
Given that most investors are
very hardware averse, especially
this day in age, where do you
expect that money to come from?
Is that something that will come
from governments or private
investing?  How are we going to
fund the future of computing is
really what my question is?
>> JOHN HENNESSY: Yeah. it's a
good question.  I mean, I think
the answer is both.
You know, certainly Google is
making large investments in a
lots of these technologies from
quantum to other thing has.  I
think government remains a
player.  So, government, you
look at how many of the
innovations we're used to.
The internet, risk, the rise of
VLSI,
modern computerated design tools
of we all had funding basically
coming from the government at
some point.  So I think the
government should still remain a
player in thinking about, what's
the one area the government has
probably funded longer than
anybody else?  Artificial
intelligence.
They funded it for 50 years
.  So we're going to have to
have that and we're going to
have to have industry as well.
They compliment each other.
They do two different things but
they're complementary and if we
can get them to work well then
we're going to have the best of
both worlds.
>> You talked a little bit about
the difference between memory
hierarchy and storage that is
coming up with these new memory
technologies.  Have you seen any
applications where
the compute and the storage get
combined kind of more like the
brain?
>> JOHN HENNESSY: Yeah, I think
increasingly we'll see things
manufacture towards that
direction where
you, the software takes care of
the difference between what is
in storage, quote, unquote
because it may actually be flash
or some kind of next generation
memory technology, and what's in
DRAM.  What you need to tell me
is, what's
volatile and when do I have to
ensure that a particular
operation is committed to
nonvolatile storage?  But, if
you know that, you know, we've
got log-based file systems,
you've got other ideas which
move in the direction
of trying to take advantage of a
much,
greatly different memory
hierarchy, greatly different
storage hierarchy than we're
used to and we may want to
continue in that direction.
Particularly when you begin to
think about, if you think about
things like
networking or I/O, and they
become major bottle necks in
applications, which they
often do, then rethinking how we
could do those efficiently and
optimize the hardware, but also
the software because the minute
you stick an operating system
transaction in there, you've
added a lot of weight to what it
costs to get to that storage
facility.  So, if we can make
that work better and make it
more transparent without giving
up protection, without giving up
a guarantee that once something
is
written to a certain storage
unit, it's permanently recorded,
then I think we could make much
faster systems.
>> So, do you see the
implementation of a
domain-specific architecture
being
implemented as heterotype or do
you see
it off die, off chip type
implementations or both?
>> JOHN HENNESSY: I think both.
I think it's a time of great
change.
The rise of FPGAs, for example,
give you the opportunity to
implement these machines, try
them out.  Implement them in
FPGA before you're
committed to design a custom
silicone
chip, put it in FPGA, unleash it
on the world, try it out, see
how it works, see how the
applications map to it and then
perhaps decide whether or not
you want to freeze the
architecture.  Or you may just
want to build another next
generation FPGA so I think we'll
see lots of different
implementation approaches.
The one thing we have to do, you
know, there was a big break
through in how hard it was to
design chips that
occurred from about the mid-80s
to about 1995 or 2000.  Things
have kind of ground to a halt
since then of the we need a big
break through because we're
going to need many more people
designing processors, targeting
particular application domains.
And that's going to mean we need
to make it much easier and much
cheaper to design a processor.
>> I'm wondering as a deep
learning engineer, for private
enterprise, what is my role in
pushing forward DSA.
>> JOHN HENNESSY: Yeah, well, I
think your role is vital because
we need people who really
understand the application space
and that's really critical.  And
this is a change.
I mean, if you think about how
much architects and computer
designers had to think about the
applications, they haven't had
to think about them.  All of a
sudden they're going to have to
develop a bunch of new friends
that they can interact with and
colleagues they can work with to
really get the insights they
need in order to push forward
the technology.  And that's
going to have -- that's going to
be a big change for us but I
think it's something that's
absolutely
crucial and it's great for the
industry too because all of a
sudden we get people who are
application experts beginning to
talk to people who are software
architects, who talk to hardware
people.  That's a terrific
thing.
>> You mentioned performance
over domain specific languages
like python but they're also
much harder to use, so do you
think software engineering
talent can keep up in the
future?
>> JOHN HENNESSY: Yeah, I think
the challenge will be the gain
we've gotten in software
productivity in the last 20, 30
years is absolutely stunning.
It is absolute stunning.
I mean a programmer now can
probably write ten to 100 times
more code than they could 30
years ago in terms of
functionality.  That's
phenomenal.  We cannot give that
up.  Because that's what's
created all these incredible
applications we have.  What we
need to do is figure out all
of a sudden we need a new
generation of compiler people to
think about how do we make those
run efficiently?  And by the
way, if the gap is a factor
of 25 between C and python, for
example, if you get only half
that, that's a factor of 12
times faster.  Any compiler
writer that can produce code
that runs 12 times faster is a
hero in my book so we have to
just think about new ways to
approach the problem and the
opportunity is tremendous.
>> Are there any opportunities
still
left in X86 as far as like
lifting the
complexity of DISA in the
software and exposing more
microinfrastructure to the
compiler?
>> JOHN HENNESSY: It's tough. I
mean, I think the Intel people
have spent more time
implementing X86s than anybody
has ever spent implementing
1ISA, one instruction set ever.
They've mined out almost all the
performance.  And in fact, if
you look at tweaks
that occur, for example, they do
aggressive prefetching in the i7
but you look at what happens
with refreshing,
some programs actually slow down
.  Now on balance, they get a
limb bit of speed-up but they
get a little bit of slow down in
other applications.  The
balance, we don't get slow down
on other things.  I see my
producer telling me it's the end
of session.  Thank you for your
great questions and for your
attention
(applause)
(Session was concluded at 12:13
PM CT)
***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.  This text,
document, or file is not to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
***
REALTIME CAPTIONING ON THIS
SCREEN
GOOGLE I/O 2018
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 10, 2018
STAGE 2
10:30 AM
ANDROID JETPACK: SWEETENING COIN
DEVELOPMENT WITH ANDROID KTX
T1260D
(APPLAUSE)
>> JAKE WHARTON: Hi, everyone.
My name is Jake.
I work on the Android team on
Kotlin stuff.
So, today, I'm going to be
talking about Android KTX.  And
I'm not going to be talking
about, I'm not going to be just
going over a bunch of the stuff
that's in there.  I want to make
it a little more interesting
than that, so I'm going to start
with a little bit of what
happened last year at Google
I/O.  I was here last year,
talking about
how you can write extensions
extensions for Android types
such as this example where we
have code that iterates over
the views inside of a view group
.  You can pull that common code
out into an extension.  What
this extension does is enhance
the type we don't control, the
view type.  We're allowed to
essentially create a member
function that's not actually a
member function.
It actually turns into a static
function in the bite code with
the functionality that we want
to enhance.
So, we can take our
original code that had the
explicit four group in it and
use the new member to create
what we wanted to do.  It is
actually distinguished between a
normal member function that it's
italicized.  If you use dark
yellow, that will actually be
yellow but the intent is to feel
semantically equivalent to a
member.
So, oftentimes, when you start
talking about extension
functions, you think,
well, if this is so useful why
don't we just put the function
directly on to view group.  Why
doesn't view group just offer a
4H
index that takes in a lamb do
-- lambda.
Really by default, that eats up
message and causes -- loading.
Kotlin, however, applies
language functionality which
allows us to eliminate that
lambda's allocation.  By marking
its function in line, the body
of the extension gets copied
into the call site and we have a
zero overhead extraction.
Let's take a look at another
example.  In API 23, we were
able to get a system service
based on a class type, and in
27.
1 of the support libraries, a
context com pat version of this
was added that
allowed it to work on all API
levels.  We can pull this into
an extension
that is also inline like the
previous one but doesn't contain
a lamb bough.
What this one has that's
different is something called
reF irk.  This is a compiler
trick that forces the type of
information of the generic to be
known at compile time so that it
can be made available at
runtime.
So, this is what allows us to
take
what we wore otherwise be
classifying,
we can now pass that on so our
calling
code can be used to pass the
generic and because it's -- the
implementation to be able to
class that Java.
So, if we want to update the
padding of
a view, just where we're only
specifying two of the four
parameters.
In this case, we want to update
both the left and the right, we
have to pull out the existing
padding from the top and the
bottom because Android requires
you to specify all four.
This is something that we can
remedy,
again, using an extension
function
.  The key here is for each the
arguments on that function we
can define, we're specifying
that default and that default
will be used when value is not
provided for had a arguing.  So,
it allows us to take the calling
code where we're specifying all
four and
now specify them as just 2 but
the problem here is that we've
eliminated two of the arguments,
but since we're only supplying
two, Kotlin takes that as
meaning the first two, and the
latter two are the ones where
the defaults are used.  This is
not what we intended.  We
intended to do left and right,
which are the first and third.
Another language feature comes
to help here, which is named
arguments.  Name parameters,
rather.
By specifying the name of the
parameter, we're able to tell
the compiler which of the
the others two arguments we're
specifying, and allowing it to
fill in the default for .  Okay.
Android APIs have a bunch of
composite types.
These are things like point,
rectangle,
pear, even the location class.
In this case, I'm calling an API
which has a rectangle which is a
composite around the left right
top and bottom values of a
rectangle.  And if you need to
do calculations based on the
value inside of these composite
types, you have to pull them
out into individual values or
variables.
In order to do that calculation,
and then potentially, put them
all back together.
So, with the help of the
extension, we can avoid this.
This one is a little bit
different.  We have a new key
word called an operator.  An
operator means that Kotlin will
allow us to use a special call
site site
syntax, and each operator
function has a very specific
name.  A well-known name.  You
can't just make up any names.
And the name defines which call
site syntax that you're
intending to create.  In this
case, it's called component.
And component allows us to use a
feature of Kotlin called
restructuring so our original
code which had to
individually pull out the four
different
components can now use this call
site
syntax where the rectangle is
automatically syntaxed into four
values and assigned to four
variables with the names that we
choose.
What's really nice about this is
that if you don't care about
ones later on, you can omit
them.  And if you don't care
about ones in the middle, you
can specify them as underscore.
And so, if we just need to pull
out
two of the values, we can do
that very succinctly.
An experienced Kotlin user might
know that -- well, can we go
back a slide?
Okay. So this is a code that
determines whether or not we can
use the string digits.  Sets a
digit using the character, and
then sets a value to default
whenever it detects a nondigit.
If you're an experienced Kotlin
user you might know about the
all function
which exists on string which
encapsulates the same looping,
allows you to specify predicate,
which in this case, is digit.
It's actually an inline function
so it desugars into the exact
same thing we would have wrote
in the previous slide.
But, what's interesting is that
Android actually has a built-in
function for this and I suspect
that a lot of people don't
actually know this exists.  And
so, this is something that we
can actually take and turn into
an extension
but you have to wonder, is this
actually worth its weight in an
extension.  What value do we
gain by turning this static
method that we can call into an
extension.
Well, for one, it changes the
way that we invoke to feel a lot
more natural and idiomatic in
Kotlin, sure.  But, still, is
there really value that we
extract from this?
The biggest one that I think we
gain from this is that when
you're in the IDE, you have your
string, and you're wanting to go
and determine whether or not
it's
, you're wanting to make this
query as to whether or not it
contains only digits, if you
didn't know that status on text
was there, you probably would
never find it.  When it's
extension, if you start typing
in the IDE, it will actually
show this extension in auto
complete where it's much more
discoverable than otherwise.
So, you just press enter and you
get it.
All right, so I covered a few
extensions here.  I just wanted
to remind you a bit of the power
of these extensions.  The fact
that we're leveraging language
features that exist only in
Kotlin, not in the Java
language, and actually some of
these examples we're going to
keep coming back to throughout
the rest of this talk
so all of the extensions that I
just
showed are part of the Android
KTX file we announced in early
February.  There's been two
releases since then, and as of
Tuesday, it's now part of
Jetpack.  And versioned with
Jetpack.
So, on Tuesday core KTX is now
1.0 alpha one.  It's going to be
versioned and
released with future Jetpack
libraries
so we called this core KTX when
we launched which is kind of a
weird name, it didn't make
sense.  This is for extensions,
for types only in the framework.
A lot of people suggested, can
we add support library stuff and
we were very adamant about
saying no.  That should
hopefully make a lot more sense
now but even this isn't exactly
true because core KTX initially
depended on support compat.
Support compat is there to
provide backwards
compatibility of versions that
are in the framework.
That came from support compat so
now with the jet packs reframing
and the Android X, support
compat has become
core and now core KTX lines up
with core.  We kind of knew what
we were doing back when we
started this and now it's only
starting to payoff.
Along with the other Jetpack
libraries,
there's actually a few new KTX
libraries launching with it.  We
have ones for fragment,
collection, SQL 8, for the newer
components, navigation and work
runtime.
I'm going to touch on how you
can discover these a bit later
but I want to talk a bit about
scoping about how you determine
whether or not something
should go into one of these
libraries.
All right so in core KTX, 0.3,
we operated an extension that
looks like this.  If you look at
its signal, an operator, it
operates on color and the
name is plus so this allows us
to use the
.  If you look inside support
compat, there is a color
utilities class and that color
utilities class has a composite
colors that allows integer
colors, allows a background and
turn them into a single  color.
So, this is the first candidate
for placing the implementation
of what that
extension function was into this
class so that everyone can use
it.
So that it can be used to the
Java language or the Kotlin
language.
So, in core KTX 1.0, this
actually has been rewritten to
just delegate to that color
utils.
So, the Java language users get
that functionality but the
Kotlin users get the enhanced
syntax.
And if you look at the
extensions that
we talked about so far, the
bodies of them, the
implementation of these
functions, they're all trivial.
They're exceedingly trivial and
that's by design.
And this gets me into
covering some of the principles
that we
defined defined that KTX
extensions should have.  This
first one is that we want to
adapt functionality that already
exists, and if we want to add
the new features, those should
be redirected upstream to a
place where they're language
agnostic where both languages
can take advantage of them.
Other examples of this was there
was
some HTML stuff and a path
iterator that implemented core
KTX that has since moved
upstream into core to be able to
be used in both languages.
Another thing that's common to
all
these extensions
extensions is that they're
inline.  The reason we do inline
on the first one, the one at the
top, is that we want to avoid
the lambda allocation.  For the
second one, because we're using
reFI generics, we're actually
forced to use inline by the
compiler.  The third, the
component ones and the
very bottom ones, are all inline
mostly because they're just
aliases to what you would
otherwise write if the extension
didn't exist.
If we look at an example of
something that's not inline in
core KTX, we have
this iterator extension to view
group
which allows us to view
Kotlin for in syntax to iterate
the view and view group.  This
is not inline for a very
specific reason and that is
because it defines, the
implementation of this function
defines an anonymous class.
If we were to inline this, that
means that every time you use
it, an anonymous class would be
defined at your call site so
this would increase your deck
size,
method Copt and class loading
.  We explicitly make this not
inline because we want that
single implementation to be
reused by all of the callers.
So, we default to an extension
being inline unless there are
allocation reasons and I should
note that this is
really only for KTX style
extensions.  No normal Kotlin
code, this is not a good
recommendation.  You don't want
to default to inline because it
has the potential to lead to
actually having a negative
effect on your code rather than
a positive one.
All right so earlier when we
showed this extension, I talked
about how the inline modifier
coupled with the fact that
there's a lambda allows this
extension
to be a zero overhead
extraction.  In the reFIed case,
we get the ability to have a
more declarative version of the
look-up at call site without
having
to specify the colon colon class
dot Java.
For updating the padding, we get
to
use default values to not are to
specify each of the arguments
and name
parameters to specify which
subset of arguments we want to
actually provide.
For the destructuring case we
get the fancy syntax that allows
us to pull
apart the component variables
out of a composite architect.
This is enabled by the fact that
we have operator  overloading in
Kotlin.  We also talked about
how we were able to add the plus
for color.
For this one, we're aliasing an
extension to a static method to
help improve explorability for
built in  helpers that you might
otherwise not know exist.
And then for types that are
collection-like but not actually
collections, we have the ability
to turn
them into pseudocollections
where we can
use the afford answer eyewitness
an cs of the language as if they
were actual collections so each
one of these has a very
Kotlin-specific language that it
uses and we want to make sure
all of
these that we're defining
leverage some use of the
language that doesn't otherwise
exist for Java collars.
We want to resist trying to fix
an API just by creating
extensions for it but rather
enhance it to become more
pleasant to use by leveraging
these Kotlin-specific features.
Okay. One of the suggestions we
get quite frequently is to take
something like set on click
listener and write an extension
which allows you to call it
using something like click or on
click.
This allows the calling code
instead
of having to call said unclick
listener we get the shorter
version of click.  Are we
leveraging a future language
here?  Well, we're leveraging
extension functions but not
really, we're really just
creating a shorter alias.
What value are we creating from
this type of extension or typing
less characters but really it's
auto completed anyway, but even
worse, what precedent will we be
setting here by adding this
extension.  Are we going to do
this for every listener?  And
so, this is a great example of
something we explicitly do not
want to
do in the KTX libraries.  If
you're not familiar with the
term,
we call this code golf where you
have
the desire to create the
shortest code possible.  This is
something we do not want to do.
We're not here to just make the
code shorter.
Okay. There's another one that
gets suggested every now and
then and that I've seen people
using.
With Android because of the
different API levels we have to
support, you very frequently see
these checks around the STK.  So
it can be tempting to pull this
out into an extension where you
have a little bit more
declarative version of this.
We move the comparison into an
extension
function, it's an inline
function so we don't have the
overhead.
The lambda is the last parameter
so we get the nice Kotlin call
site syntax and
it turns our if statement from
this into this.
Now, this by itself is not too
terrible.  We're really not
leveraging any of the
language features again similar
to the last one.  It's still
kind of an alias but at
least this one you can argue a
little bit more for its merits.
But, there's a problem.  While
these two statements are
equivalent, what happens when --
for one thing is that you can at
least static import STK in and
then they're a little bit closer
so that's one reason why this is
less justified.  But, one thing
is that an if statement is a
very primitive construct of a
programming language.
And because an if statement is
not just an if statement,
there's constructs like else.
So, what if your requirements
change such that you need to
alter the behavior
on these two different versions?
Well, if you were using this
extension that you wrote in
order to support this  case, you
either have to change back to
using an if statement, or you
have to
modify the function where maybe
it takes two lambdas now, one
fortification where you're above
19.  One for the case where
you're not.
Because we're not taking two
lambdas in this function, we've
lost the special trailing lambda
syntax where we now have to pass
them as arguments inside the
parentheses whereas before we
didn't.  So, immediately, this
extension starts falling apart.
If we introduce another
conditional branch, maybe we
need to vary the behavior across
APIs in three different ways.
Well, there's really no way that
we
can make the extension do this.
The other thing that is
different about this extension
compared to the if statement is
that we're assuming the
conditional that we want to
check is greater than or equal
to, that the behavior we want to
run in the lambda,
we only want to run on, you
know, 19 plus.  Well, a lot of
times some of the if
statements, again, STK ints will
be less than or equal to so now
we need a second extension in
order to support that use case.
So this is another example of
something that we're not looking
to do.  We don't want to
optimize for just a
single use case or a specific
use case
where the extension only
supports one way of doing
something and then when you need
to move to something more
complex, you have to revert to
the original behavior.
We want the extensions to allow
you to express everything you
would need to
express if it didn't exist.
Okay. So all the extensions
we've been
talking about thus far have been
ones that are in the core KTX
library.
I don't want to go through a ton
of the extensions that are in
these other libraries.  Again,
I'm going to show you how you
can discover them in a
bit but I want to touch on one.
So, for the fragment KTX, we
have an
extension which encapsulates
transactions.  We move the begin
transaction and the commit
function calls into an
extension.
We use the fact that we can use
an inline function and the
lambda again to turn this into a
zero overhead thing.  Our
calling code then becomes a
little bit shorter where we now
use the transaction with a
lambda body.
So if you've used fragments,
you'll know that commit is not
the only commit function.
There's actually more than one.
So we can model this by doing
something like allowing you to
apply bullying as whether you
want to allow state loss or
disallow state loss when you're
committing.
This is really easy to
accommodate.  But it sort of
goes against something I said
earlier where you can update
your call sites to be able to
use this, it sort of goes
against something I said
earlier, though, wry talked
about
minimizing the impact of the
implementation of these
extensions.  Since this is an
inline function and
we've now put a conditional
inside the
inline function, that
conditional is being inlined
into all the call sites so all
the call sites have to have this
conditional inside of it, so is
this
actually a bad thing
.  You
You don't really have to
understand byte code.  There's
essentially three function
calls.  The first one is
transaction w the second one is
that place inside the
lambda and the third one is just
a call to commit allowing state
loss.  There's no if statement
here.  There's no conditional.
And that's because since this is
an inline function and since the
argument
is a
boolean, the compiler actually
knows what time.  So since it
can be compiled and eliminates
the branches that can never
possibly be executed so you
actually get
in byte code what's equivalent
to what you otherwise would have
written.
There's actually more commit
functions.  There's one which
will allow you to commit now and
commit, so we can also
support that by adding an
additional boolean.
The same thing happens even
though they're now nested, dead
code will make
it so there's only one call in
the resulting byte code.  Okay.
As part of this effort of all
these releases at I/O, one of
the things that
we've done is start creating a
Kotlin-specific view of the
libraries that we publish and
the Android framework itself.
So, if you see in that blue box
there
when you visit the
reference docs it will ask you
if you want to review a
Kotlin-specific and
also if you scroll down to the
page, at
the very bottom we have links to
them as well.
And what these are are a Kotlin
view of these libraries.  So
when you're browsing through,
say, the fragment package,
you'll be able to see the
extensions for fragment inside
the documentation.  That's no
longer completely separate.
One thing that's missing right
now is we don't actually tell
you the Maven coordinates of the
artifact that these come from.
That's coming soon.
And also the extensions
in core KTX which extend the
platforms sites don't actually
show up on the platform docs.
But this is something we wanted
to get out to show you it's
being worked on so hopefully
those two things will be coming
soon.
All right.  I want to touch on
-- you know, I'm
here to talk about Android KTX
but Kotlin extensions, there's
nothing Android specific about
it.
What we're doing is building
extensions it try and make these
libraries more Kotlin friendly
and that's something that any
library can do
so I want to talk about the ways
that we think about how we can
make libraries
more Kotlin friendly that apply
to both the Android libraries
but also apply to libraries you
might be writing or you might be
using.
The first way it make a library
really Kotlin friendly is just
rewrite the whole thing in
Kotlin.  I mean, obviously this
isn't feasible for every library
but it's certainly an option for
some.
If it's a library that's private
to
your app, it's in your
repository or internal to your
company and you're already using
Kotlin, this is a viable option.
Doesn't seem like something
that's totally viable for, say,
the Android framework and I'm
not quite sure we're at the
stage where an Android X library
could do this
maybe a future Android X library
could be written in Kotlin.
That seems like a strong
possibility.
What we've chosen to do with
most of the
things that we publish is
sibling artifacts.  So the main
library remains written using
Java language and we ship Kotlin
language features as a sibling
artifact.
What's great about this is you
don't force the Kotlin standard
library on to your consumers
unless they explicitly want it.
You can curate the extensions to
be exactly what's needed to
augment API
where you get the Kotlin
specific features and what's
really nice about this is you
don't have to control the
library that you're extending so
if you're just consuming a
library and you
want to make part of it more
Kotlin friendly, you can do
that.  You can do that either in
your own app or you can publish
a set of extensions
for a library that someone else
publishes.
But, are these the only two
options?
I want to take a look at
something that I think will lead
into a third
somewhat hybrid option
.  I'm going to go back to the
simple
alias message where we've taken
a Kotlin in the Java and turned
it into Kotlin language.  If we
look at the implementation of
this class on the Java side,
I've included the first line
because we can see that it
immediately dereferences the
argument that we pass in.  As
soon as we pass in a string, it
says, you know, what's the
maximum number of characters
that I can iterate over in order
to determine whether or not
there are digits.
And so, if you've been using
Kotlin with Java APIs, you might
know that this
means that the parameter is
going to be exposed as what's
called a platform type.  It has
unknown  nullability.
But, from the implementation, we
know
right away that this method
simply cannot accept null
values.
And way that we would fix this
is by
adding the non-null annotation.
So what this annotation does is
it
informs the Kotlin compiler that
there's
a restriction
, that there's special behavior
it needs to take into account
where it needs to enforce that
no one passes a potentially null
value or null into this method.
So, this is something, this is
enabling a language feature in
Kotlin that simply doesn't exist
in Java.
Now, you can
use tools that will allow this
enforcement to work for Java but
it's not intrinsic to the null
itself.  So if we can do
something like that
for nullness, add this
annotation to  nullness that it
needs to change its behavior
when we invoke this method, can
we do this for something else?
Say, I want to take this static
method where the first argument
is really the receiver and can I
say this is actually going to be
an extension function when
invoked from Kotlin?
And what this allows us to do
potentially is eliminate the
need to
have this explicitly defined
extension at  all.  Right?  This
extension only exists it change
the calling convention to inform
the compiler that we want to
allow you to call it in a
different way.
So now we're left with just
this, the Kotlin compiler sees
the annotation just
like it saw the nonnull
annotation, infers something
from it and allows you to call
in a way that's more idiomatic
for that language.  In the byte
code, we get what we otherwise
would have written, right?
We get the call to the static
method and the receiver becomes
the first
argument
.  How about this example?  One
thing you might have noticed is
this extension is named update
padding, not set padding.  Now,
we can actually call this
extension set padding, but the
problem is that it will only
work for a subset of arguments.
So.  In this case, where we're
just passing
left and right values, we could
call that set padding and it
would work fine.
But if we passed left right and
then top bottom, we'd be
supplying four arguments and the
Kotlin compiler is going to see
that the real set padding also
excepts four arguments and it's
going to prefer calling the real
one.
And the real one doesn't have
name
parameters so you're going to
get a compilation error.  That's
its reason we have to name this
update padding.
If we look at the real set
padding, simple method that
takes four integers,
what if we could inform the
Kotlin compiler that these
parameters have
names associated with them
.  Now, it would be nice to
infer this
just from the parameter, not the
set -- but I'll argue that for
one it's very nice being
explicit about these names in
the annotation.  In Java 8 byte
code, there actually is a way
for you to retain parameter
names so the Kotlin compiler
could in theory use those but
one problem is that then it
becomes an all or nothing thing.
You have to opt into this
behavior and
then suddenly every parameter
name
across your library is set in
stain whereas if it's
annotation, it's something you
could incrementally migrate.
So, this has the potential to
solve
the naming part where now we can
call
the real method from Kotlin and
specify the four orders from any
order we want based on what
names we provide.  The default
value.  What if we could pass
in, what if we could specify an
expression, a Kotlin
expression which allowed the
compiler to
.  This would change our
original
extension calling convention
from calling our extension to
actually just using the real
method.  And then in the byte
code, we get the thing that we
started with.
The thing that our explicit
extension would inline to but
now the extension doesn't have
to exist.
The metadata that we added in
the form of annotations inform
the Kotlin compiler that we
wanted to enhance our ability to
call this function in a Kotlin
specific way leveraging the
Kotlin features.
And so we're able to do so.
This is something, so Kotlin has
this
process which is called KEEP.
Kotlin evolution and enhancement
process.
And just this morning, we
proposed these annotations as
KEEP110.  So, this is something
we're proposing
to add to the Kotlin compiler so
that it can understand these
annotations.  We have extension
function and extension property,
which are for static methods.
Default value, which allows
supplying
default values for our
parameters, and then KT name,
which allows you to provide an
alternate name for methods,
feels, or parameters.
It's very important to note that
this is extremely early.  These
names might change.  The
semantics might change.  This
may never actually be skepped
into the Kotlin compiler.
We have been working with the
jet brands team for quite a
while on this and some of this
is already prototyped inside the
Kotlin compiler.
We really think this could be a
way to enhance the framework for
Kotlin callers
without actually having to go in
and rewrite the Android
framework for at least its API
and Kotlin, which is really not
feasible.  And it's also
important to note that while
this is an option assuming that
it actually make it's into the
Kotlin compiler, it doesn't
totally solve every problem that
our existing extensions are
solving.
We determined these annotations
that we
proposed in KEEP 110 through
looking
through a bunch of open source
libraries, looking through our
own libraries, and seeing what
we thought would be the most
useful extensions.
What would be the pattern of
Java
methods with such that they
would want to be turned into
extensions.
And so, the latter two really
are complementary.  The big
advantages of the annotations is
that you retain the single
source of truth.
You don't have to really know
Kotlin.  You don't have to add
Kotlin compiler to your build
system.
You don't have to publish
sibling artifacts.  If you're a
pure Java library, you can add
these annotations and just
enhance your API so that Kotlin
callers get the more idiomatic
syntax.
All right, so to sum up core KTX
is now
part of Android Jetpack,
versions of Android Jetpack
released with Android Jetpack.
There's a few new artifacts as
you can see here on the screen,
there's definitely more coming.
Notable ones that you think are
missing, are slices and V model.
I would not be surprised to see
artifacts for those in the
coming months.
Please check out the Kotlin
version of the reference
document, yeah, the reference.
You know, this is extremely
early.
We're -- this requires changes
in DAC
doca and how we produce docs.
It's something we want to get
out and
show you a preview.  This is
definitely something being
actively worked on.
There's a new component for
Android KTX.  Because Core KTX
and all the KTX libraries are
now part of Jetpack, the source
of truth has moved into the
Android support repository.
We're going to be migrating the
GitHub
issues on the GitHub project
over to this bug tracker in the
coming weeks but
it's important to note that
we're still gob accepting core
requests to the GitHub repo and
syncing things back out to the
GitHub repo.  It's just that
issues will no longer be the
source of truth on GitHub of the
it will be on the Android
tracker.
The KEEP was proposed, I created
the poll request about an hour
ago.  Please go check that out.
The document contains a lot more
detail about examples.  And like
I said, the annotations that
were chosen were the ones that
we think have the most impact
but at the bottom of the
document you'll see that if
something like this gets
accepted,
there's a potential for future
enhancement of even more.  The
link to that should be this.  I
made this link last night before
I
submitted it so hopefully it's
accurate.  And that's it.  Thank
you.
(applause)
(Session was concluded at 1:10
PM CT)
***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.  This text,
document, or file is not to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
***
REALTIME CAPTIONING ON THIS
SCREEN
GOOGLE I/O 2018
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 10, 2018
STAGE 2
11:30 AM
TENSORFLOW AND DEEP
REINFORCEMENT LEARNING WITHOUT A
PHD
TAF466
>> Hi, everyone. Hello.
Welcome to this TensorFlow
session about reinforcement
learning.
So, this is Yu-Han, I'm Martin,
and today, we would like to
build a neural network with you.
Do you know with neural
networks?
>> AUDIENCE: Yeah
>> MARTIN GORNER: Serious
question.
If I said Softmax or cross
entropy, raise your hand if you
know what that is.  Like half of
you.  Okay. Very quick primer.
This is a neural network.  Okay?
Layers of neurons of those
neurons, they always do the same
thing.  They do a weighted sum
of all of their inputs.
And then, you can
layer them in layers.
The neurons in the first layer
will be doing weighted sums.
The neurons in the second layer
will be doing sums from the
first layer and if you're
building a classifier, let's say
here you probably want to
classify those little square
images into airplanes and
nonairplanes, you will end up on
a last layer which has as many
neurons as you have classes and
if those
weights
are configured correctly, we'll
get to that, then one of those
will have a strong output.
Tell you it's an airplane or the
other one will have a strong
output and tell you this is not
an airplane.  Okay?
There's one more thing,
activation functions, so a
little bit more detail about
what a neuron does.
For those who like it, you have
the full -- yep.  Right here.
You havele full transfer
function here
so you see it's a weighted sum
plus something called the bias.
That's just an additional degree
of freedom and then you feed
this through
an activation.
And so simplify for us here,
only two activation functions
that count.
So, for all the intermediate
layers, the wide layers, that's
the simplest
function you can imagine
.  We love it.  Everyone uses
that.  Let's not go any further.
On the last layer, though, if we
are building a classifier,
typically what you use is the
Softmax activation function and
that is an exponential followed
by a normalization.  So, here, I
have different classifier
that classifies in ten classes
.  You compute the norm of that
ten vector elements and divide
everything by its norm.  The
effect of that since exponential
is very steeply increasing
function is
that it will pull the winner
apart.  I made a little
animation to show you like this.
This is after Softmax.  This is
before Softmax.
So, you see
much clearer which of those
neurons is indicating the
winning class.  That's why it's
called Softmax.
It pulls the winner apart like a
max but it doesn't completely
destroy the animation, that's
why it's the soft version of
max.
Okay.
So just quick application to
that we can build the stuff we
want to build.  So, now, coming
out of our neural network, we
have let's say ten final neurons
producing values which have been
normalized between zero and one.
We can say those values are
probabilities.  Okay?  The
probability of this image being
in this class.
How are we going to determine
the weights in those weighted
sums?  Initially, it's all just,
you know, random.
So, initially, our network
doesn't do
anything
actually so useful.  We do this
through supervised learning so
you provide images which you
have labeled beforehand, you
know what they are.
And of those images, your
network is going to output this
set of probabilities but you
know what the correct answer is
because you are doing supervised
learning.  So, you will encode
your correct answer in a format
that looks like what the network
is producing.  It's the simplest
encoding you can think of.
It's called one-hot encoding and
basically it's a bunch of zeros
with just 11 in the middle at
the index of the class you want.
So, here, to represent six, I
have a vector of zeros with a
one in the six position.
And now, those vectors look very
similar.  I can compute the
distance between.  Them.
And the people who studied this
in a
classifier, they tell us don't
choose any distance.  Use the
cross-entropy distance.  Why?  I
don't know.  They are smarter
than me.  I just follow.
And the cross-entropy distance
is
computed like this so you
multiply element by element, the
elements of the vector, the
known answer from the top by the
logarythm.  You just sum that up
across the vector.  This is the
distance between what the
network has predicted and the
correct answer.  That's what you
want if you want to train a
neural network.
You get this, called an error
function or loss function.  From
there on, TensorFlow can take
over and do the training for
you.  You just need an error
function.
--
And the error function that we
are going to use is the
cross-entropy error function
that I have on the previous
slide.  Okay?  All good on this?
Bit of code.
This is how you would write it
in TensorFlow so there is a high
level API in TensorFlow called
layers where you
can instantiate an entire layer
at once.
You see
I instantiate the first layer,
has 200 neurons and is activated
by the RELU here.  This also
instantiates weights and biases
in the background.  You don't
see that.  It's in the
background.
I have a second layer here,
which this one is just 20
neurons.  Again, early
activation function, and this, I
need to do this little final
layer so it's a dense layer
again with two neurons, and even
if you don't see it on the
screen, it is activated by
Softmax, but you don't see it
because I use its outputs in the
cross-entropy function which has
Softmax build ten.  It is a
Softmax layer.  It's just that
you don't see written Softmax in
the code.
Finally, this here is my error
function which is the distance
between
the correct answer here, one-hot
encoded, and the output from my
neural network.  Once I have
that, I can give it to
TensorFlow, pick an optimizer,
ask it to optimize this loss and
the magic will happen.  So, what
is this magic?
TensorFlow will take this error
function, differentiate it
relatively to
all the weights and all the
biases, all the trainable
variables in the system, and
that gives it something that is
mathematically called a
gradient.  And by following this
gradient, it can figure out how
to adjust the weights and biases
in the neural network in a way
that makes this error smaller.
That makes the difference
between what the network
predicts and what we know to be
true smaller.  That's supervised
learning.
So that was the primer.  Now,
what do we want to build?
Today, we would like with you to
build
a neural network that plays the
game of pong.
But just from the pixels of a
game.  It's  notoriously
difficult to explain to a
computer the rules of I game,
the strategy, all that.  So you
want to do away with all of
that, give it the pixels and
find some learning algorithm
where it will learn to play this
game.  And of course, that the
not the goal
in itself because figuring out
how to program a paddle to win
pong is super easy.  You just
always stay in front of the
ball, you know?  And you win all
the time.
And actually, we will train
again such
a computer controlled agent
.  The goal here is to explore
learning algorithms because this
has applications, hopefully, way
beyond pong.
So, this looks like a
classifier.  We just learned how
to build a classifierment of we
have the pixels.  We will build
a neural network and it has
three possible outcomes.  This
is a position in which you want
to go up, stay still, or you
want to go down.  Okay. Let's
try to do this by the book in a
classifier.
So, we have a single
intermediate
layer of neurons, activated with
the RELU, of course, and then a
last layer where there's three
neurons activated by Softmax.
We use the cross-entropy loss,
so you have the function here.
It's the distance between the
probabilities that this policy
network,
it's called a policy network,
predicts
.  Probability of going up,
going down, and the correct
move.  But, what is the correct
move?  I don't know.  Do you
know?  Yu-Han?
>> YU-HAN LIU: No, Martin,
you're exactly right here.
Unlike in the supervised
learning problem, we actually
don't know what's the correct
move to play here.  However, the
environment requires that we
keep making moves of going up or
staying still or moving down to
progress again.  So what we're
going to do is sample
the move which means picking one
of the three possible moves of
moving the pedal up, staying
still or going down randomly.
But not completely randomly,
though, we're going to pick the
move based on the output of the
network.
So, for example, if the network
says
the output probability of going
up is 0.8 then we should plaque
it so that there's 80 percent
chance we choose to move up as
our next move.
>> MARTIN GORNER: All right so.
Now we know how to play the
game.  The policy network gives
us probabilities, we're all
loaded dice and pick from that
and we know what next move to
play.
But initially, this network is
initialized with random weights
so it will be playing random
moves.
How does that inform us about
the correct move to play.  I
need to put the correct move in
my formula.
>> YU-HAN LIU: That's right.
So, in this case, we really want
the correct move to mean moves
that will lead to winning.  We
don't know that until someone
has scored a point, so that's
what we're going to do.  Only
when someone either our panel or
the other panel has scored a
point do we know if we've played
well or not.  So whenever
somebody scores, we're
going to give ourselveses a
reward.  If our pedal scores a
point we'll give ourselves a
positive one reward point and if
the opponent scores then we give
ourselves a negative one reward
point, then we're going to
structure or losses slightly
different than before.
Over here, you see some, a loss
function very much like the
cross function we saw before.
Now, in the middle here is the
main difference where instead of
the correct label in supervised
learning problem,
we're just going to put the
sampled move in here.
The move that we happen to play.
And
some of the moves might not be
moves that will help us and
that's why every loss value is
multiplied by the reward out
front.  This way moves that
eventually lead to a winning
point will get encouraged and
moves that lead to a losing
points will be discouraged over
time.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Okay. So you
do this for every move.  I can
see how with this little
modification it could lead to
some learning but putting back
my mathematician's hat on, I see
a big problem here.  You have
this sampled move.  That is a
picking operation, the sampling
operation.
You pick one out of three.
That is not differentiable.  To
apply the minimization and
gradient
and all that, the loss function
must be differentiable.
>> YU-HAN LIU: You're right,
partner, asking the hard
question here.  The simple move
here actually does depend on the
model's weights and biases but
the simple operation is not
differentiable.  So we're not
going to differentiate that.
Instead, we're going to look at
sampled moves as if they are
constant and then we play many
games across many, many moves to
get a lot of data, treating all
of these sample moves as if
they're constant and only
differentiating the
probabilities that are output by
the model in blue here on the
screen and those probabilities
directly depend on
the models ways and biases, and
we can differentiate those.
With respect to the ways and
biases
are respect to the gradient,
looking at gradient techniques.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Okay. So you
kind of cheated.  The part that
is automatic just regarded as
constant you're going to play
many games with the same neural
network, accumulate those plate
moves, accumulate those rewards.
Whenever you know that you
scored a point, you accumulate
those rewards and then you plug
that in and you only
differentiate relative to the
predictive probabilities.  Yes,
you're right.  That still gives
you a greatent that
depends on weights and biases so
we
should be able to do that.
Okay. I get it.  This is clever.
So, this will actually train
probably very slowly.  Here, we
want to show you the minimum
amount of stuff you need to do
to get it to train.  But in the
minimal amount, there are still
two little improvements that you
always want to do.
The first one is to discount the
rewards.
So,
probably if you lost a point,
you did something wrong in the
three, five,
seven moves right before you
lost that point and probably
before that you bounced the ball
correctly a couple of times.
And that was correct.
You don't want to discourage
that.
So it's customary to discount
the rewards backwards through
time with some factor so that
the moves you play closest to
the scoring point are the ones
that count the most.
So, you see the, here we
discounted them with a factor of
one half, for instance.
And then there is this
normalization steps.  What is
that?
>> YU-HAN LIU: That, that's very
interesting.  So, in experiments
we noticed putting in the
normalization really helps
training.  There are multiple
ways to think about this.  The
way I like to think about this
is in the context of playing the
game.  You see, at the beginning
of the time the model only had
the randomized ways
and biases so it's going to mawk
random moves but most of the
time it's not going to make the
right move.  Only once in a
while it's going to score a
chance by accident.  Most of the
time it's going to lose pointses
and we want to find a way to
naturally put more weight to the
very rare winning moves there so
they can learn other corrective
moves and performing this
normalizing and reward steps
here naturally gives a very nice
boost to the rare winning move
so it does not get lost in a ton
of losing moves.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Okay. So let's
go.  Let's train this.
We need to play the game and
accumulate enough data to
compute this everything we need
for this function here.  Okay?
So those are the sampled moves.
We need the rewards and we also
need those probabilities which
the network
can compute from us from the
pixels so we are going to
collect the pixels during game
play.
That's how our collected data
set looks like.
You have one column with the
move you actually played.  One
column where you would like to
see
the probabilities predicted at
that point but you are actually
going to store just the game
board and run the
network to get the probabilities
and the last column with
rewards.
You see there is a plus one or
minus one reward on every move
that scored a point and all the
other moves, you discount
that reward backwards in time
with some exponential discount.
And once you have this
maybe you notice in the formula
you
just multiply those three
columns together and sum all of
that, that's how the loss
computed.  Let's build it.
You implemented this
demo is can you walk us through
the code?
>> YU-HAN LIU: Let's do that.
So up here, you see a few
TensorFlow place holders.  You
should really think of them as
functional arguments that are
required
to compute alpha values for
model.
So with three place holders for
input, one for observation,
really this means the difference
between two consecutive
frames in an instance.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Yeah we didn't
say that.  Just from the game of
pong you don't train from the
pixels because you don't see the
direction of the ball from the
pixels but you train from the
Delta of two frames because
there you see the direction of
the ball.  That's the only
wrinkle we're doing here
specific to pong.  All the rest
is reinforcement learning that
applies to many other problems.
>> YU-HAN LIU: That's right and
for the actions place holder,
it's just going to hold all the
sampled move.  The moves that
the model happen to decide to
play, and the rewards place
holder will collect all the
discounted rewards.  Now, with
those as inputs ready to build
the model, the network is really
simple like the one Martin
showed before.
It has a single dense layer, a
single dense hidden layer with
the activation
of the RELU function, 200
neurons, followed by a Softmax
layer.
You don't really see calling a
Softmax function here and that's
really because the next step,
the sampling operation already
takes in values you get before
you close off max function and
it can
perform multinomial sampling
which just means you output a
random number of
zero, one, or two for the three
classes we need output based on
the probabilities specifyied.
>> MARTIN GORNER: And this one
has the Softmax built in.
So this is a Softmax layer, you
don't see it on the code but it
is.
Just a parenthesis for those not
familiar with TensorFlow,
TensorFlow builds a node or
graph with operations
in the memory so that's why out
of
multinomial we get an operation
and then we will have an
additional step to run it and
actually get those predictions
out and place holders are data
you need to put in when you
actually run a note to be able
to get a numerical result out.
Okay.
So we have everything we need to
play the game.  Still nothing to
train.  So, let's do the
training part.  For training, we
need a loss function.
So, our beloved
cross entropy loss function
computing
the distance between our
actions, so the moves we
actually plate, and logics which
are from the previous screen,
that's what the network predicts
from the pixels.
And then we modify it using the
reinforcement learning paradigm,
we
modify it by multiplying this
per move loss by rewards, by the
per move rewards.  And now with
those rewards, moves, leading to
a scoring point will be
encouraged.
Moves leading to a losing point
will be discouraged.  So now we
have our error function,
TensorFlow can take over.
We pick one of the optimizers in
the library and simply ask this
optimizer to minimize our loss
function which gives
us a training operation
.  We will on the next slide run
this training operation feeding
in all the data we collected
during game play, that is where
the gradient will be completed
and that's the run that will
modify the weights and biases in
our policy network.
So, let's play this game.  This
is what you need to do to play
one game in 21 points.
So the technical wrinkle is in
TensorFlow if you want to
execute one of those operations
you need a session, so we do a
session and we play the game.
First we play the game stage,
complete the Delta between two
frames.  Okay. That's technical.
And then run this sample
operation.  Remember, sample
operation is what we
got from our picking multinomial
function.  So, that's what
decides the next move to play.
Then we use
a pong simulator here from open
AI gem.
We can use the mode it play,
give us a reward if we score,
and give us information on
whether this 21 game is
finishes.
That's all we need.  Now we
simply log that stuff.  We log
the pixels, the move we played,
the reward if we got one.  So we
know how to play one game and we
will play many of those games to
collect a large backlog of
moves, right?
>> YU-HAN LIU: That's right.
Playing DMs in reinforcement
learning or in our experiment
really is a way of collecting
data.  Now that we have
collected a lot of data, playing
one game, only ten games, why
not.  We can start processing
rewards as we plan to.  We'll
discount the rewards so that a
move stuff did not get any
reward during game play, now
gets a discounted reward based
on whether or not they
eventually
led to winning or losing points
and how far they are from the
moves actually one or loss a
point and then we normalize
rewards such as before.  Now
we're ready.  We have all the
data in place.  We have
observations, that's the
differences between game frames.
The actions that we have and the
reward so that we know if those
actions were good or bad, and
then we're ready to call the
training op.  And training op is
what we saw a couple slides
before where we had optimized
already initialized and this
going to do the heavy lifting
and compute the gradients for us
and modify the weights just
slightly.
Suppose we play ten games,
modify the
weight slightly, play more games
and get even more data.  And
repeat the process.  The
expectation or the hope is that
the model will learn to play a
little bit better all the time.
>> MARTIN GORNER: I'm a bit
skeptical.  Do you really think
this is going to work?
>> YU-HAN LIU: Well sometimes we
see the model turn into player a
little bit worse so we'll see.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Okay. Live
demo?
>> YU-HAN LIU: Live demo.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Let's go.
Let's run this game.
So this is a live demo.
I'm not completely sure that we
are going to win but we'll see.
So, brown on this side is the
computer controlled  paddle.
Very simple algorithm, just
stays in front of the ball at
all times.  There's only up with
way to win.
Vertical velocity is limited so
you have to hit the ball on the
very side of the paddle to send
it at a very steep angle and
then you can overcome the
vertical velocity of the
opponent.
That's the open way to score
.  On the right in green, we
have our neural network
controlled agents and it's
slightly behind now so we'll see
if it wins.  And if you wanted,
I want this side of the room to
cheer for brown and this side of
the room to cheer for AI.  Okay?
It is very even right now.
One -- yeah, go, go, go.
(cheering)
>> MARTIN GORNER: AI is winning.
AI is winning.  I'm happy
because this is a live demo.
There is no guarantee that AI
will actually win.  One thing
that is interesting here,
actually, is that  you, this is
learning from just a pixels.
So, initially, the AI had no
idea of even what game is was
playing, what the rules were.
It had even no idea which paddle
it was playing, okay?  And we
didn't have to explain that.
We just gave the pixels and on
scoring pointses we give a
positive or a negative reward
and that's it.  From that it
learns.  And you see those
emerging strategies.  Like what
I said, hitting the ball on
the side and sending it at a
very steep angle is the only way
of winning and it picked that
up.  We never explained it.
It's just an emerging strategy.
This is looking good.
>> YU-HAN LIU: Pretty close.
Yeah.
>> MARTIN GORNER: It's looking
good.  It's a bit close but
looking good.  You think we'll
win?  Okay.
Next point I want a loud cheer
when AI wins because I hope this
is going to work.
(groaning)
(cheering)
>> MARTIN GORNER: Hey 20, one
more.  Yay, we won!
>> YU-HAN LIU: We've done it.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Good job,
Yu-Han.  This is fantastic.  All
right.
So, what was going on
during game play?  Remember how
the network was built?  Remember
neurons first have a weight for
every pixel and it's fairly easy
to represent those weights on
the board and see what those
neurons are seeing on the board.
So,
let's try to do that right here.
We picked eight of those 200
neurons and here we visualize
superimpose on the board the
weights that have been trained
and the untrained eye doesn't
see much here so maybe you can
analyze.
>> YU-HAN LIU: This is really
interesting, Martin.  We are
looking at what the model sees
so rather what the model cares
about
when it sees the game pixels we
gave it.  You see one of the
neurons has learned pretty much
nothing.
It's still looking like white
noise at the beginning.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Bad pixel.
Didn't listen.
>> YU-HAN LIU: It doesn't
contribute much to the game play
but for the other neurons you
see an interesting pattern.  We
see things the model seems to
put a lot of weight on.  It
cares a lot about where the
panel is, where it's moving.  It
not cares about the triage
equity rei across the game
board.  Quite interestingly it
also cares about where its own
panel is on the right because
like Martin pointed out
before, at the beginning of
learning,
the model didn't even know which
panel is playing.  It has to
learn to remember, that's an
important piece of information
to be able to play a game well.
When you think about this this
is really consistent with how we
humans believe important
informations to be able to play
the game well.
>> MARTIN GORNER: So we wanted
to show
this to you not to show our
prowess at pong, although it
worked.  But mostly to explore
training
algorithms and you see
mostly in neural networks you do
supervised training and in
nature, sometimes when we teach
people, it looks like supervised
training.  Probably in class,
the teacher says,
this is, you know, the Eiffel
Tower and people say, Okay.
That's the Eiffel Tower and so
on.  But if you think about a
kitten
jumping on a fur ball and
missing it and jumping again
until it catches it, there is no
teacher there.  It has to figure
out a sequence of
moves and gets a reward from
catching the ball or not
catching it.  So it looks like
in nature there are multiple
ways of training our own neural
network and one of them is
probably quite close to this
reinforcement learning way of
teaching.
Yu-Han, you built this model.
Is there some other thought that
inspired you?
>> YU-HAN LIU: Yeah, I have a
sort of
technical insight, maybe, for
you as a takeaway message.  In
running experiment, we see that
there are some stats which are
not differentiable.
Particularly in this case
sampling a move of the
probability output from the
network and playing a game
getting the rewards back.  Yes,
those factors really do depend
on
the model itself but in a
nondifferentiable way so even
with tools like TensorFlow you
wouldn't be able to build a loss
function in gradient training
but there are ways to get around
it, and that's exactly the
techniques we're showing today.
>> MARTIN GORNER: So what you're
saying is that reinforcement
learning can solve many more
problems than just pong and it's
a way of getting around some
nondifferential step that you
find in your problem.  That's
great.  That's great.  So where
is this going?  We want to show
you a couple of things
from the lab because this has
had mostly
lab applications and then one
last thing.
What is  this?
>> YU-HAN LIU: This is very
interesting, everyone.
What we're witnessing here is a
human expert of pancake flipping
trying to teach a robotic arm
doing the same thing.
And there's a model in the back,
those
output controls the joint
movement.  The goal of this is
to flip the
pancake and the pancake.  Rather
implemented with sensors, so he
knows he's been flipped if it
landed on
the floor or on the table or
back in the frying pan.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Doesn't seem
to be working.
>> YU-HAN LIU: It's trying. In
a common experiment --
>> MARTIN GORNER: So what is the
reward here?
>> YU-HAN LIU: The reward
probably is if you flip a
pancake correctly then you get
positive reward and otherwise
negative reward.
Speaking of reward function, in
another experiment, I was going
to say, the experimenters set
the reward to be a
small amount of positive reward
for any moment the pan kick a is
not on the
floor and that machine, the way
it
learned was to fling the pancake
as high
as possible to maximize pancake
airborne time that way it can
maximize reward just because it
takes a long time to land on the
floor.
>> MARTIN GORNER: That's kind of
funny but it's a nice
illustration of the fact that
you can change the learned
behavior by changing your loss
function.
>> YU-HAN LIU: Exactly. The
model learns.  Now you have to
learn.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Oh, nice.
Cool.
We know how to play pong and
flip pancakes.  That's
significant progress.  Deep mind
also published this video.  So,
they used reinforcement learning
and built those skeleton models.
Here, the neural network is
predicting
the power to send to the
simulated muscles and joints of
these models and the reward is
basically a positive
reward whenever you managed to
move forward and a negative
reward when you even move
backward or fall through a hole
or just chummable to the ground.
The rest is just reinforcement
learning as we have shown you
today so all of these behaviors
are emerging behaviors.  Nobody
taught those models.
And look, you have some
wonderful emerging behaviors.
It's coming in a couple of
seconds.  Look at this jump.
After this, those are nice
jumps, but there is a much nicer
one in a second.
You will see a jump.  An
athletic jump with the model
swinging arms to get momentum
then
lifting one leg, cushioning
right here, look at this.
This is a fantastic athletic
jump.  It looks like from the
Olympics and
it's completely emerging
behavior.
What is it.
>> YU-HAN LIU: But Martin, if
this is optimal way of walking
around, why do I not see people
doing this?
>> MARTIN GORNER: Well, there
are multiple ways of running.
Probably the loss factor didn't
have any way of discouraging
useless movements so again, by
modifying the loss function, you
get different behaviors.  And
actually one last one, not this
one, this one is kind of funny,
still playing around.
But, look, here, it's figured
out how to run sideways of the
this is fantastic.  Yes, there
are two ways of running and
it did figure out how to move
sideways.
This one you've probably seen.
This is move 74 in game 4 of
alpha go
versus Lisa Doll and that's the
one move
that Lisadol played called the
guard move.  He's world famous
for that.  He played one correct
move and managed to win one game
against alpha go.  He lost four
to one, which is fantastic.  And
alpha go also uses reinforcement
learning, not exactly in the
same way.  Here it wasn't
entirely built out of
reinforcement learning, okay?
Because for turn-based games,
the algorithm for winning is
actually quite easy.
You just play all the moves to
the end.
The only problem is you can't
compute them.  There are too
many of them.  So you use what's
called a value
function, you unroll on your
couple of moves and use
something that looks at the
board and tells you this is good
for
white and good for black and
that's what they built using
reinforcement learning.  And I
find it interesting because it
kind of emulates the way we
lines solve this problem.  This
is a -- humans solve this
problem.  This is a very visual
game.  We have a very powerful
core text when
we look at the board go as
influence and see in this
region, black has a strong
influence.  In this region,
white has a strong presence so
we can kind of process this and
what they built is a value
function that does kind of the
same thing and allows them to
unroll the move to a much
shallower depth because after
just a couple of moves their
value function built using
reinforcement learning tells
them this is great for white or
good for black.
So these are results from the
lab.
Let's try to do something real
real.
Let's say we have build
characters.  We structure it so
that those characters represent
a neural network.  Yeah, a
neural network is sequence ever
layers.  This is my first
syntax.
Why not represents a neural
network
.  Let's say you have a entirely
network you care about, let's
say, spotting airplanes in
pictures.  So, this will train
to give some accuracy.  What if
now we take this accuracy and
make it a reward in a
reinforcement
learning algorithm
.  Let's say, we create a better
neural network, not just
changing the parameters,
changing the shape of the
network that works better for
our problem we care about.  We
get a neural network that is
generating a neural network for
our specific problem.  It's
called neural architecture
search and we actually published
a paper on
this, and I find this very nice
application of a technology
designed initially to beat pong.
>> YU-HAN LIU: So Martin, you're
saying we have entirely networks
that learn to build other neural
networks.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Yeah.
>> YU-HAN LIU: That's deep, man.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Yeah, so,
Yu-Han, to finish, you built
this demo, so can you tell us a
word about the tools that you
used?
>> YU-HAN LIU: Yeah, definitely.
So we used TensorFlow for the
model itself.  And TensorFlow
for tracking the metrics of
during the process training.  I
really didn't want to run the
training on my laptop though I
probably
could, so I used Cloud machine
learning engine for the
training.  The model that was
playing again for
the live demo took maybe one day
of training to accomplish that.
>> MARTIN GORNER: So we have
this job base with you and you
can launch 20 parameters and let
them run.  It's just
practicality, right?  It will
tier down the whole cluster when
every job is done and so on.
>> YU-HAN LIU: That's right.
Worry free.
>> MARTIN GORNER: Yeah, I use
engine ML for that.  There are
many tools for doing machine
learning on Cloud but one we
just launched is ML engine.
That's one you do not program.
You put in your data, it figures
out the model for you and now
you know how it works.
Also, this uses lots of CPU, GPU
cycles.  Cloud CPUs are useful
when you're doing neural
architecture search and they are
available to you as well.  So,
thank you.  That's all we wanted
to show you today.  Please give
us feedback.  We just released
this code to GitHub so you have
the GitHub URL if you want
to train a pong agent yourself,
go and do it.  You can take a
picture there.  If you want to,
the URL is still on the screen.
If you want to learn machine
learning, I'm not going to say
it's easy, but I'm not going to
say it's impossible either.
We have this series relatively
short
series of video and code samples
-- called code samples without a
PhD that
is designed to give you the keys
to the machine learning kingdom.
So you go through those videos.
This talk is one of them and it
gives
you I vocabulary, all the
concepts.  We are trying to
explain the concepts in a
language that developers
understand because we are
developers.  Thank you very much
(applause)
(Session was concluded at 2:10
PM CT)
***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.  This text,
document, or file is not to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
***
REALTIME CAPTIONING ON THIS
SCREEN
GOOGLE I/O 2018
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 10, 2018
STAGE 2
12:30 PM
IMPROVE APP PERFORMANCE WITH
ANDROID STUDIO PROFILERS
TC069E
it has is you can change the
background.
So
if the internet connection is
good enough, this is going to
start downloading.  So maybe
just right now.  There you go.
Can you dive into the network
Profiler.  You surely have seen
these before and you can see all
the network requests that have
been done.  You can click on
them and see the actual pay
load.  Something new that was
added in 3.1 is the ability for
us to see what we send.
Not just what we receive, but we
can see the pay load or the
custom headers that we use.  In
this case, I have one custom
header that says, Google I/O.
There is another new feature in
3.1 for the network Profiler,
and that is the threads view.
So, as you see here, we show you
the requests in the timeline,
but if you choose threads view,
what you can
see is on which thread, and let
me close this so we have more
space.  There we go.  So you can
see each request on which thread
it was made.
And if we have more like this,
I'm
using a standardized synchronous
task
which uses a default executor
that will
run them sequentially and you
can see them.  If they were
using a different thread, you
can see that, too.  But if you
have a more complex threading
with network requests, you can
use this to see what's going on.
So, those are the two new
features on
the Network Profiler that we've
added in 3.1.  Now I'm going to
move to the Memory Profiler.
Let me go to the live session.
If you have seen this view
before, we split up how much
money we are using but
we also show you the number of
objects we have allocated.
If you are profiling on an
Android phone or newer, this is
super cool, we have a feature
called live allocation tracking.
Remember back in the day, it was
probably last year, when you had
to do
allocation tracking, you had to
click on a button to record
allocations and then you can see
them.  Well, if you wanted to
know what happened here, we can
see that the
object lines going up as being
garbage collected, going up.
Just select a range and we will
have the information on every
single October that was
allocated there, at which time
it was allocated, and where in
your code it was allocated.
And you can slide this window
and see it thing changing.  So
if I slide it over a garbage
collection period, you will see
which objects were deallocated.
Let me close this window.  There
we go.  We can see that there
was a lot of strings
deallocated.  So we can start
actually having a look
at this app and ee how bad it is
written.
For example, it if I select this
and I want to see what was
allocated, I can see there were
a lot of strings allocated.  I
can click on any of those.  I
can see where I allocated.
And I allocated them inside a
nondrawer.  This is not a good
idea if you have a custom view
and you allocate a lot of
strings here but things will
happen.
And we'll see more about that,
the CPU profiler.  This is more
to tell us signals about what my
app is doing wrong.
Another new thing that we added
in 3.
2 is the ability to see JNI
global references.  This is very
important because a lot
of memory leaks occurred, 1YNS
is created and we don't know
where we created it and we don't
know where it is.
So when you select a range I
have here
in my app every time I download
an image I run a filter to
darken it so the font can be
seen.  And I have a global
reference there and I hope I did
right, right?
So, we have a special heap which
we
call the JNI heap that when you
select it you can see all the
global references that exist in
this time.
In this case, I have the -- and
I know I created one but it
should have been
gone so let me go live here and
select a range.
And here it is.
This is my global, this is every
image that has been loaded.  I'm
still holding a JNI global
reference to it and I can
actually navigate to the C plus
plus line of code.  When I
created that global reference, I
never let go.  So I hope this is
useful to track down problems
with global references in JNI.
And one more thing.  You
probably have been seeing all
the time on the left that we
have a new panel called the
sessions panel.
Well, now we allow you to see
previous sessions that you have
been profiled so
you can navigate back and
compare previous runs.  If
you're working on optimizing
your app, see, what did I
change, you can go back and see
previous sessions.  At the end
of the demo, hopefully, we can
go back and see what we
optimized and what happened.
But that opened the door for us
to do things like this.  Now we
can import a file.  I'm going to
import.
And this
heap dump is being imported
directly and you can analyze the
heap dump as you're using
Profilers.
You can trace the CPU and
everything we can import we can
export, too.  So that's pretty
handy, this is new in 3.2.
Cool.
And this is what I wanted to
show for memory.
And now we're going to go to CPU
and spend most of the time
there.  Right.
Right.  This is the live
session.
And I'm going to show you one
feature that you have.  All
right.
So one thing we wanted to add
was the ability to profile from
the beginning.  If you use the
profilers, you have to quickly
go to CPU Profiler and hit
record so you can see what's
happening.  Well, in 3.
2, what you can do is you go to
the profiling tab, we have an
option that says start recording
a message trace on start-up.  So
I have the stick, you can choose
the configuration you want.  In
this case, I'm going to use a
sample Java configuration and
I'm going to rerun the app.
Cool.
Now, you can see that the app
restarted.
The profilers took me directly
to the CPU Profiler and there
are already a capture in
progress from the very beginning
of the app so I'm going to stop
it now and we're going to
investigate what happened there.
Take a few seconds to get the
data.  Cool.
I don't know if you can see the
resolution on the screen, but
let's have
a look and see that I'm going to
select the very beginning of the
app.  In fact you can see that
the capture
started even before or telemet
rei.
It started here but we started
before, and we get the data.  If
you keep zooming there you can
see the first on create of my
main activity
and even before that, we can see
the load and the very, very
beginning of your app.  And with
this mechanism, you can profile
from the very beginning.
Optimize the start-up time.
Cool.
But, let's have a look at this
capture
and see if those strings we saw
before
are actually causing some
problems.
One of my favorite views in the
CPU Profiler is the flame chart.
The flame chart aggregates all
the call steps that have the
same beginning.  So you can see
it's basically the top down tree
but in a visual way and you can
see that one of the biggest
things
is my own draw.  Drawer.
The way I wrote this app is on
every frame I'm rendering
everything again of that's not a
good way of doing it but it's a
really good example for the
Profilers.  So you can see that
I'm rendering and there is a lot
of things at the top that
have to do with string
formatting and this could be the
source of our string problem
that we saw before.
So your string is not doing
well.
One thing I always say about
profilers is that we cannot
really tell you what's wrong in
your app.  We can only tell you
what your app is doing and then
it's up to you to say, oh, I
didn't expect this to happen.
Because as you can see, my app
looks fine but under the hood,
it's not.  So, let's say you
have a bug on a label that you
put wrong and it's a different
position.  You're up, you see
here.  I need to fix this.  But
if you have something like a
performance issue wrong, you
won't see it until we talk about
battery later, and you will see
it in the field.  Right?  So we
want our profilers to be another
window to your app
so that you can run your app
while seeing the Profilers.
Something you did not expect
start showing up like me doing a
lot of string formatting.  Cool.
So, let's go to the code.
What I have -- can you see?
Yeah.
Cool, so I have my own drawer
and I have a fucks called draw
time where I draw the time on my
app.  And I have another
function called draw time string
that uses
blank string formatting to draw
the time and that's probably not
a good idea so as a coincidence
I have another function that
draws the time without using
strings and we're going to try
it.  Oh, before we do it, let me
show you one thing that we have
here.  So, how many of you are
familiar with this line of code?
Trace out begin section.  Raise
your hands.  Cool.
So, what this line does and
together they will create a
sis trace event.  I'm going to
show you what happens if I take
a capture using the system trace
method.  Cool.  So this is
running sys trace under the
hood and you don't have to go to
the Python script anymore and
get it and then get it back on
the HTML view.  We will,
instead, show it to you right
here in our app.  In Android
Studio.  Okay.
Remember what I mentioned about
-- this is it.  Oopsie.  Let me
restart even later.  I will do
it again.
There we go.  Please, please,
try this at home.  Find bugs.
We will fix them and when we get
this
table, these issues will be all
sorted out.  There we go.
I'm going to go to CPU Profiler
and use system trace.
Second time's the charm.  Okay.
So we have system trace here.
Let me select and zoom into the
selection.  Cool.
One thing that you notice here
is that
first of all you have a new
section here called the kernel
section where we show you all
the CPUs.
And if you pay close attention,
we reran all the thread
information getting all the data
from sys trace.
So, before, the string
information, we
get sampling
the profile system so it's not
very accurate but as soon as we
take a sys
trace
you can see more.
More than that, we highlight
above on
which CPU, so we can see all the
things kicking you out of the
CPU.
There is a fundamental
difference in the way we show
sys trace here.  Here, we focus
on your app, so everything here
that is highlighted green, even
the dark green is just your app.
You can still go and see the
other
events and see what is taking
CPU or why you're being kicked
out, but we focus on your app.
We show you the trace of your
app so
you don't have to inform gate
this gigantic list.
So, for example, flame chart or
top down view.  So, let me zoom
in the moment in time.  There we
can see our frames.
So, I have here, let me zoom in
more and choose actually my main
thread.  There we go.
So, we can see the frame and
further
down we can see the
on draw on my custom component.
And we can see the draw time.
Remember the code.  Let me go
back and show you in draw time
we have draw time around the
section around my temp frame.
You can see I'm running it in
three sections and we can
quickly see how long
each one of those it taken so
I'm taking 38,000,002nds to run
the frame.
If you want your app to run in
60 seconds, you have to run it
on 17th frame, milliseconds.
So, I'm way over that.
In fact, one of my calls to draw
time
is taking 11 milliseconds.  So
my app is not doing so well.
This is one of the things that I
was mentioning about, you look
at your app, but look at it
through the profiler glass to
see if it's doing okay.
Cool, now, let's optimize and
take another sys trace capture.
I'm going to change
implementation of
draw time.  Now instead of using
strings, I'm using my custom
formatting.  We'll run it again
with these changes and run it
through sys trace and see how
that affected my app.
Cool.
There is  There it is.  I'm
going to go to CPU Profiler.
Just a few seconds should do
because
there are a lot of frames that
happen in there.  Cool.  We have
it here.  Right.  Main thread
selected.  Zoom into a specific
frame.
We have the choreographer do
frame in the framework and then
it goes down, and you cannot see
anymore the draw time functions
because they are tiny, tiny
specs down there.
Each one of them now taking
71 microseconds and the on draw
is 13 milliseconds now.  Woohoo.
So, we did that.
I'm still under 60 per second
because my app is bad in other
places but at least we optimized
one part of it.  Cool, and
that's sys trace.  And let me
mention again sessions, so
remember I said you can go back
and compare.
I have my previous sessions on
the left.
We can see the previous sys
trace we did.
Can select it, look, see how bad
my draw time is and go back to
the currently running session.
Of course, if you right click,
you can export or on the heap
dump you can export these things
right from the sessions panel.
Let me click this.
Right.  And that's our -- we
have 20 minutes.  And that's our
integration with sys trace.
So, there's another way of
capturing
CPU data that is through an API
in the debugger.
Let me go to the line of code.
Here it is.
So, I have my stopwatch.  And
I'm going to change it so every
time I start my stopwatch, I'm
going to run, start method
tracing and every time I stop
it, I'm going to stop method
tracing.
I need to import the debug and
I'm going to rerun the app.
Now, before this, once you run
this API, you have to go on and
fetch this file
and open it in either any of
your favorite Profilers that can
open a trace file.  But right
now if I'm the CPU Profiler and
I use my stopwatch, this is what
happens.
So, now I'm taking a capture and
the Studio Profiler has detected
that a
capture is being fetched and
we're showing you theirs.  And
when I stop it, we pull it from
the device and show it there so
if I start and stop, start and
stop, all these captures that
are actually overriding each
other we're pulling and
showing them on Studio so that's
super handy when you want
exactly a Profiler a moment in
time.
We can navigate to all of them
and you
can see them here here in the
sessions panel, too.  So it's
pretty cool.
One more thing, we added in
three to one.
Another way of capturing CPU
usage
using the C plus plus.
Something called simple Perf, if
you
go to documentation on
developers, you will find
documentation about simple perf.
We have it inside Android Studio
and
it allows you to sample C plus
plus code and your C plus plus
problem.  I'm not going to demo
that because I don't have a lot
of C plus plus.
Cool, so, that's CPU profiling
and let me move to the energy
Profiler now.
So, energy is tricky.  Energy is
tricky because there are two
main sources that use energy on
your phone.  Well, the screen is
obviously, I'm not even counting
the screen.  The screen is bad.
It uses a lot of energy but the
user is using the game, so if
you're using a game, it's all
the time using the screen.  But
the battery drain problems
usually happen when we use CPU
or network when the user is not
aware of this or maybe when we
as developers are not aware of
this.
So, let me go live.
I'm using a fair amount of CPU
on this
app and if I go into the energy
Profiler, we classify this as
light use of energy.
We will show you here things
that, this is -- mobile.  Right?
So we share the things that
represent how much energy you
would be using on modern phone.
I'm not profiling how much
energy the emulator is using,
obviously, but this is for us to
see, okay.  I'm doing well or
I'm not doing well.  I'm going
to show you something that shows
up here.
But obviously, the two big
factors are CPU and network.
And it's not, you know, the
obvious thing is Okay. Just
don't use CPU and network.  But
how?  Right, or why am I using
that in the field?  And the
problem is not actually when we
use it.  The problem is that we
don't know we're using it.
So, let's say I have a wake lock
that runs amok and we don't know
where it is and that's using CPU
or I have an alarm
that I didn't set up correctly
and that is walking my app and
I'm making network requests.
So, it's not about the actual
energy.  It's about all these
things that you could be doing
incorrectly that could cause
battery drain in the long term
and this is part of what I was
saying before that if you look
at your app, if you look at my
app, seems to be running.  Seems
to be fine.
If I were to push this app to
the Play Store and you're
starting on your phone, this is
going to be the most expensive
battery speaking clog you ever
have on your phone.
I'm going to drain your battery
and I don't know it by looking
at this so by looking at the
Profilers we can see that
constantly this is draining CPU
and we can start investigating
why.
Lied,like I said, the common
mistakes are I
have a wake lock I don't release
or I have an alarm.  We want to
given you a window.  We want to
show you if you have an a living
room you didn't cancel or an
alarm in the wrong place, we're
going to show you that.
So, let me show you this piece
of my app.  We have a timer.
So, here, I can run, let's say,
a 102nd timer.
And you can see at the bottom of
the energy Profiler, there is a
yellow line that showed up.
That's an alarm or a job, we
show you both there.  And you
can see that when the timer
stopped, the alarm went away.
And if I start the timer again,
again, I have the alarm.  And
this, actually, when I was
developing this was useful for
me to see, okay, am I doing it
right.  When I stop the timer,
does my alarm go away?  When I
start again, do I call it back?
So this allows you to see this.
Please don't use alarms for a
timer and a clock.
I also have a wake lock on my
stopwatch.  Again, don't use
wake locks for a stopwatch.  And
you can see that when I start
it, I acquire a wake lock.  And
when I stop it, I let it go.
And I can see that it's working
fine.
If the alarm gets going, have a
bug.  My app will look the same
and I will ship it and people
will have problems but you can
see through this window whether
it's fine or not.  And we also
track location.  So, if you are
acquiring location like I'm
doing now, we have this purple
line that shows you that your
current location, the emulator
has a really
handy feature that you can
actually tell it when to send
the location event.
So, in our model, we show you
that that is actually using
energy.  And again, you can see
it in the
purple bar and if I stop it,
there we go.
The purple bar is gone.
But more than that, I see used
to our Profilers we can select a
range.  And we can show you that
you had an alarm.  That you had
a location request.  If I move
back, we can select the wake
lock and I'll do it in a second.
More than that, I can show you
where
the location is acquired, which
kind of provider.
I'm using a GBS Profiler.  They
have a toggle location that
happens when I click the button.
And if I click on the alarm, not
only I can see when I set it the
first time, but when I reset it,
when I cancel it so you can see
all the places in the code that
that was triggered so I can
debug problems when this is not
happening correctly.
Let me go back and show you the
wake lock is right there.  I
select, you can see the wake
lock.  And you can see every
time that I
started, I stopped the
stopwatch, I was acquiring and
releasing the wake lock
and you can see all the calls.
That's when that happened.  So,
this is the power for this.
This is not to say, okay, you're
using a lot of battery.
Well, again, I want to use
battery.  So, it's fine.
The power of this is so that you
can see your app is doing what
you think it's doing.  If not,
you should go and fix it.  So
cool.
That's Energy Profiler.  Let me
show you one more thing that I
wanted to show you.  On the
left, we have the sessions
panel.
And let's go back in time.
I can stop a current session
like this.  And then you can
click on other sessions and we
can start comparing all the
captures that we did back from
when
I started to talk here.
And this was the first time we
run it and we keep all this
information until you restart
Studio so you can compare runs.
And let me show you the last
thing, and I want to close with
that.
I'm going to close a few minutes
early.
All right.  Like I said before,
I'm rendering every frame.  I'm
doing something that I should
not be doing, that is I'm
invalidating the view all the
time and that is using a
lot of CPU so let's go back to
my activity where I have the
code.  So, I have my model that
I update
every frame and then I
invalidate all the time.  My
model has the ability to know
when it has changed so I'm only
going to invalidate the canvas
whenever something has changed.
And we're going to see the
impact that
that has on energy CPU and so
forth.
Running the app again.  There we
go.
You can see now that energy
Profiler most of the time now is
below light.  It was above
medium before.  We can compare
with previous sessions.
But, of course, when I have to
render, we can see that the
energy usage starts going up.
This is because I'm rerenderring
my view every time.  And you can
see the effect here.  You can
see it on the memory Profiler,
too, if I go back to the memory
Profiler.
Remember that line that was
going up,
up, up, about being garbage
collected.  That is gone.
I do have some objects that will
be claimed later like here but
it's not as it was before.
Cool.
And let me stop the demo and go
back to the slides.
All right.  We have a few
minutes for questions if you
wanted to do live questions but
I wanted to close with this and
say, again, our Profilers cannot
tell you exactly what you're
doing wrong.
They can only show you what your
app is doing so use your
Profilers to look at your app
and see if what you think the
app is doing is what it's
actually doing.  Thank you very
much and I'm open for live
questions
(applause)
>> Okay. So with the integration
of the system trace in the new
IDE, is there any
reason to use the old sys trace?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: So far,
yes.  We are going to try to
import everything that the other
sys trace used to have but if
you want to have an overview of
the system and see how your
obligation is interactive with
other processes.  Yes.  But for
most of the things, in fact,
if you have your own system
events, can you use Android
Studio and you don't
have  to leave that ID.
>> Cool. Thank you.
>> My question is I mostly use
system
trace in order to detect frame
drops.
Have you guys integrated a frame
drop
thing, frame drop detection into
Android Studio?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Well, we
could show you how long each
frame is taking
to run, the information is there
in sys trace but it's really
difficult for us to know why,
right?
So even if you take a sys trace
with Android Studio right now,
you will see the choreographer
frame and you will see how long
it's taking so you can
immediately see the pattern,
right, and you'll see your
frames taking alonger so you'll
see when you drop frames.
When we're working on custom UI
to actually show you and
highlight frames that you have
dropped.
>> Hi. I actually have two
questions.
So, the first one is,
whether the number from the
emulator is
reliable or not so when you're
under CPU Profiler, whether the
time spent on costs are
reliable.
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Well
obviously the emulator will be
different from the device but it
can give you a relative
comparison with your other
methods.  So, in fact, the
emulator is faster in many cases
than a device.  But
proportionately, things will
take the same amount of time.
So, if your draw is twice as low
after your optimization, you can
expect the same pattern to be on
the device but if you want to
accurately profile the device
you have to do it on the device
itself.
>> So my second question is you
didn't show the method course
tap.
So, can I get the number of
cores for this method?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Yes, one
of the capture methods is the
instrumentation capture.  That
one will tell you exactly how
many times
the method has been called in or
out.
With sys trace, the method you
care about.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi, first of all, great talk.
Great updates.  My question is,
if I obtain a sys trace trace to
other methods, can I open it up
in the new Profiler?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Yes.
You can import it in the next
version.  It will be in 3.2.
You can import a trace.  The
main thing we're working on is
when you import it, it has other
processes.  They're all the same
so we're working on choosing the
pretty processes that is for
your app so we can show you
there or ask you if you want to
select which processes you care
about.
>> All right. Excellent.
Thanks.
>> Hi, what is the compatibility
of these Profilers on different
devices and OS versions?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: So, our
Profilers run on art only, so
that rules
out kitkat and I believe it's
from lolly
pop up, but we, all our features
are available on Android Oreo.
We degrade  gracefully back so
the other platforms that don't
have the things that we use, you
suddenly, start, things
disappearing.  Like you don't
have this line or that doesn't
show up because the platform
doesn't have it.  So I would say
the best platform to use is O.
You will have Profilers going
back.
But, Oreo is our target.
>> Thanks.
>> Hello, I see there's a Java
Profiler,
there's a Navien Profiler.  Is
there a Profiler to show the
Java
stacks and the native stacks in
a single view?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Not yet.
But it's happening, so I think
this is already out there.
The newer versions of simple
support
and as soon as we do that into
import Studio and that works for
us, then you'll be able to see.
What I with like to see is the
hybrid
calls start going from Java,
back to JNI, back to Java and
you can analyze all of that, so,
yes, it's going to happen.
>> Cool. Thank you.
>> Hi. Great talk.
When I analyze sys trace files,
I
often see that main thread is
slipping during the execution.
So, there is a method call and
there is a slip somewhere
inside, and that means that
there is a problem.
There is some
synchronized meta or other lock
that breaks the execution.  And
the question is, are you
planning to do some automatic
analysis of these
to find out that shared
preferences get in blocks the
execution?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Well,
this is back to what I was
saying that we are not
opinionated in telling you when
you did something, might not be
wrong.  So you're saying, there
are slips.  Slips are okay.  You
can have slops in your code and
this can be part of your design.
So, just the fact that a thread
goes to sleep is not a bad
thing.
But, if there is thread
contention, you should be able
to see it while using the CPU
Profiler as it is right now.
So, you can see especially on
sys
trace, you see if your thread is
waiting, is runnable, or is
running.  And those three
differences are very important.
If it is runnable, you're not in
sleep.  You're ready to run but
there are many
other threads using the CPUs
that have more priority than
you, whatever, and you didn't
run so you're not on the slip
but you didn't run so you need
to look for that.
And the other scenario is when
your thread is sleeping then,
yes, it could be because you are
asleep or you are waiting on a
section or something else and if
you do have a deadlock then you
need to analyze it like that.
You need to lock at which
threads are stopped and where in
your code and start feeling out
whether that's intentional or
not.
>> Yeah, but I just thought that
might
be a red flag or yellow flag --
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Your
thread will
show up as waiting, so, if it is
in user space, it will show up
as waiting, and that's your
flag.
>> Thank you.
>> Hey.
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Hello.
>> Is there a existing way to
attach a debugger without
relaunching the app so
that we can debug points when
you launch?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Can you
speak more in the microphone?  I
can't hear you.
>> Okay. Is there a way you can
attach a
debugger so debugs when it
launches.
When you launch the app so we
hit the debugger.
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Well, if
I understand your question, no.
Right now, the only way is to
attach
the the Profilers on a
debuggable app and attaching the
debugger while at the
same time profiling do things
that you don't want to do.  We
are planning on allowing you to
run
the Profilers on a nondebuggable
app so there are no issues
because of the debuggable
information in the app but we
don't have that yet.
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> Hi.
I wanted to know when you use
the Profiler when you have the
more images in the app, is there
any way to see like I see the
bit maps, but is there any way
to see the preview of those
images?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Previews
what, sorry?
>> Preview of the images, bit
maps?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Not at
the moment, no.  But if you want
to file a bug with the feature
requests, we'll look at it.  And
I'm going to hang around after
this, and I'm going to be in the
sandbox if you want to ask more
questions.
But, I'm going to be kicked out
of the
stage in nine, eight, seven.
Yeah, your question is fine.
>> Okay. Is it possible to use
the Profilers with an app that
isn't built with Android Studio?
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Yes.
>> Because some of the features
stop working when we --
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: If you
are using
an Oreo phone and your app is
debuggable you can build it with
whatever you want.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Thank
you.
(Session was concluded at 3:10
PM CT)
***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.  This text,
document, or file is not to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
***
Realtime captioning on this
screen
GOOGLE I/O 2018
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 10, 2018
STAGE 2
2:30 PM
MIGRATE YOUR EXISTING
APP TO TARGET ANDROID OREO
T30174
>> All right.
Welcome to
migrating your app to Android O
and beyond.  Hi.  I'm Fred
Chung, develop eradicate.
>> DAN GALPIN: Hi, I'm Dan
Galpin, develop eradicate.
>> ERIC KUXHAUSEN: Hi, I'm Eric.
Not a develop eradicate.  I'm
the lead software engineer
responsible for migrating the
Google
Play Store app to target API 26.
Thank you for joining us on the
last day.  This is where they
scheduled the most anticipated
sessions except for that
funny improve one that we don't
record.  Sorry, home viewers.
So, you're here for what is
really the
grand fin finale of Google I/O.
>> Well, let the grand finale
begin.  Why migrate?
There are lots of reasons but
foremost in your mind,
especially in your on
Google play, is that for new
apps by the end of this year you
must be target egg
at least API level 26 or Android
8.0.  Likewise, for app updates,
they must also by targeting at
least API level 26 by November
of 2018.
That is if you wish to consider
using app updates going forward.
>> Now, every new Android
version introduced changes that
bring
significant security and policy
, and enhances overall.  Some of
these only have apps through
their target SDK management
attribute, also then as target
API level.  In fact if you try
to upload a SDK
with a target less than 26,
you'll see a friendly reminder
like this.
>> And I'm here because we
wanted to keep updating the Play
Store app on Google Play after
the November deadline.
>> FRED CHUNG: So, let's go over
some basics real quick,
everyone.
Minimum SDK is the lowest
platform
version your app is willing to
support.  It's ultimately tied
to multiple penetration of
variation Android releases.
>> The compile SDK is literally
the SDK headers in stub library
that your project links to.
>> And the important one, of
course, is the one I'm talking
about.  The target SDK version
is the
platform's way to ensure
backwards compatibility.  It
means you only have certain
behavior changes applied as
certain target SDK versions.
>> FRED CHUNG: So, technically,
this needs to be true.
And this is typical and
recommended case since you
probably care about 95 percent
of users out there that are not
quite targeting the latest
versions of Android just yet
although we are working to
improve that.
>> So if you don't change your
target SDK to at least version
26, you might
not have to deal with things
like runtime permissions,
AlarmManager changes, coming up
with different ways to handle
broadcastreceiver actions and
avoiding background services.
>> But there's a good chance
your app will waste network and
battery while making the device
experience less fast and fluid.
>> So, if you are migrating from
a
preinversion, one of the biggest
changes are about runtime
permissions.  Really about user
privacy and trust
but also for apps to ask for
sensitive permissions in
condition text and that's a good
thing for apps.
You don't want someone to not
install your apps just because
you are asking for permission
for sensitive information
in one particular flow within
your app.  So, first of all, not
all permissions are runtime
ones, just this simple, easy to
remember list.
>> But worry not, developers.
You can think of these the way
the user sees them in terms of
these broader categories and the
first question you should have
is whether the app really needs
the permission at all.  After
all, removing the permission is
easy.  Now, Eric, how did the
Play Store app handle this?
>> ERIC KUXHAUSEN: Well, it's
simple.  All you need to do is
make sure their app is
pregranted the permissions on
the systems image.
>> FRED CHUNG: That's not very
helpful, Eric.
>> ERIC KUXHAUSEN: That being
said, we try to use as few of
these as possible.
And of course, just because your
app isn't yet targeting M, it
doesn't even
your users can't go and disable
any permissions they want to
have.
>> FRED CHUNG: And there are
special permissions you need to
redirect.
For example, overlay windows or
permissions like screen capture.
>> ERIC KUXHAUSEN: Now, being
the work of the UI, runtime
activity require fragment that
is overridden the method.  This
means that your view layer like
activities and fragments need to
anticipate any permissions
actually required by the other
layers.  All right, here's a
great transition.  Let's talk
about alarms.
Alarms and Android take two
basic forms.
They are literally alarms that
allow
an app to wake itself up to
deliver a notification of some
realtime event such
as waking you up or an upcoming
appointment, or they are a way
of scheduling work to happen at
some time in the future after
the app is closed.
And at the beginning of Android,
this was a single API.
But back in Kitkat, we made
AlarmManager not exact unless it
was explicitly requested which
makes it better for scheduling
future work.  Now, if an app
needs to notify the user at a
precise time, we added the
method set exact, and here's
where we've implemented a method
in the support
library to call it on kitkat and
above.
>> We don't use any exact alarms
in the Play Store app.
The alarms we do use are inexact
which allows the system to batch
them for better battery and
system health.
Now HMarshmallow added those
which would
allow it to go -- so we added
the method
allow while idle to allow the
harm from doze and note that it
actually calls the previous
support library method for said
exact on earlier platform
versions.
>> FRED CHUNG: So after all that
exposition, the take aways are
pretty simple.
Consider moving work to DCM, a
job via work manager.  Work
manager is the newest work
scheduling thing that we launch
the.
>> ERICA JACKSON: Now, work
manager is a part of --
>> Now, work manager is a part
of Jetpack and chooses the best
things to
run such as API version and app
stay, and when it becomes stable
it will be the recommended API
forerunner tasks unless we come
up with something better before
then.
>> Play Store was able to see
our background tasks regularly
reach 2
percent more users on kitkat
with we
adopted Firebase -- this
includes system and battery.  If
you do have to use the alarms,
use
the least exact ones you can
>> FRED CHUNG: Now, remember
that the
most exact alarms should only be
used every 15 minutes or so, so
you should only be using those
judiciously.
>> Oh, yeah. Work manager.
So, let's talk again about
broadcast receivers.
>> Should we talk about
broadcast receivers?
>> Yes.
>>
>> FRED CHUNG: So, broadcast
receivers, I think many of you
probably know that,
right, that's used by the
platform to notify and launch
apps in response to system-wide
events.  It's one of the reasons
that Android has such a powerful
API service.
>> Now, with great power, comes
great responsibility.  And it,
in response to the way that
these end points have been used,
most of these can no longer
launch your app.
At least once you target O.
>> Well, there are exceptions,
of course.  It's Android, right?
Many of these happen very rarely
such
as changes in locale or in some
cases there are just no
alternatives yet to the
broadcasts that need them.
For example, like those USB
accessory ones.  Let's check on
example of how to avoid using
broadcasts.
So, for a job, you can do so by
setting up the proper criteria
and network service, and then
you have functionality that's
comparable to listening to
network state change broadcasts.
And if you do have code like
this in
your manifest on older versions
of Android, you can disable the
listener to the connectivity
change and, you know, just leave
it disabled and then what are
you going to do?
You can then enable the receiver
by setting the component enable
setting in the package manager.
>> Another exception is if you
need to perform any tasks after
your package has been updated,
for example, rescheduling alarms
or updating your database.  You
can still register receiver in
your manifest for the action my
package replaced which continues
to work because
it's one of the explicit
broadcasts targeted just to your
app.  Now, if you really need it
did some work in every package
update and you probably don't
because you can no longer be
launched by action pack replace
events but we do have an API
called get change packages which
allows you to see what
packages have changed since the
previous save sequence number.
Now, in life, running is usually
healthy, I probably should do
more but Android app wants to
run as little as possible.  Lazy
apps are actually better apps.
I should make a manifest or
something.  Fred, what do you
think we should actually --
>> FRED CHUNG: Sounds good to
me.  First of all, let's talk
about what it means to be in the
foreground because it's not
completely obvious, right?
There are some typical cases
like when your app is visible to
users or when you're using
foreground service or if
your app is bound to a
foreground app so
your app is also in the
foreground in these exceptional
cases.  Your app is in the
background when you're not
visible such as when it's
running a standard service,
broad service or broadcast
receiver.  And when you're on O
plus, starting a
service when running in the
background
will TensorFlow an exception
called illegal stature exception
which is not good.
>> Now you can start services
when your app is in the
foreground and they'll continue
to run for about a member after
your app is backgrounded.  This
is important because the system
releases any wake when you have
no components such as activities
or services.  This applies to
all apps, not just apps
targeting O.
>> There are a few cases where
your app is still allowed to run
if it's foreground and start
services.  For example, in
response to
notification action, a high
priority is Cloud message or in
response to MMS or SMS delivery.
So, let's talk through some
solutions forerunner in the
background without background
services.
>> First of all, you use DCM
fire job -- fork manager for
background tasks.  Now, there
are many good reasons for this.
It creates a consistent API
surface across many Android
versions, for example.
>> Or if you don't care as much
about having your app behave
consistently across platforms,
but want to move to O with the
least amount of work required,
you can also use Java intent
service
>> But seriously, consider using
work manager.
Leverage its constraints and
make your life easier.
>> So,le Google Play Store app
didn't have the analyticsy of
using work manager because it
didn't exist yet.
That meant we had to use job
scheduler and Firebase job
dispatcher.  Now the first thing
we learned is not o to use job
scheduler on Android L unless
you really understand it and
have alarm watch dogs when it
doesn't behave as expected.
Also, use workarounds.
For example, on L and the first
release of M, job scheduler
won't actually run your job
unless there are two jobs with
the same constraints met.  You
can work around this by
scheduling two jobs with
matching constraints.
>> But seriously, like, work
manager.
>> Work manager.
>> Things do get much better for
job scheduler on MR1 and above.
However, another quirk is that
you
should avoid calling set minimum
latency to zero.  This could
interfere with the override
deadline on some releases.  The
override deadline is a way of
making sure your job runs with a
fixed period of time even if the
constraints aren't met.
>> Or you could just use work
manager
which doesn't actually have
override deadlines but what you
should do is schedule a second
job as a watch dog to perform a
similar function.
>> Here are a few things to
consider when oozing job
scheduleer or work manager.
Android tries to cover captive
portals but it's an imperfect
art.  In addition, Android will
occasionally wake up your app
right before network is
available for your app.  All
this means is you need to have
proper error handling to ensure
rescheduling of jobs.
When play store added
exponential backoff to our jobs
we saw 19 percent more
successful background tasks.
The key here, though, is let the
system do its work.  It's easy
to make the mistake of
rescheduling with the same job
ID while
also using system backoffs.
This can interfere or even reset
the backoff rate.
>> DAN GALPIN: Or with
WorkManager, actually, yeah,
don't do that either because it
will have the same results.
>> FRED CHUNG: So, for APIs that
require that you use pending
intents you can change the
pending intent targets from
service to a broadcast receiver.
Now, if your task will execute
within
30 seconds, you can then call go
asynch and run the work within
your broadcast receiver with h
by the way is
a super light weight getting
things done.
You aren't guaranteed to have
network or wake locks so there
are still many ways where you
should.
>> DAN GALPIN: Schedule a job
within your broadcast receiver
using work manager.
>> FRED CHUNG: So if you have
externally
triggered time sensitive event
that's require immediate
attention consider using
Firebase Cloud messaging to
notify your app.
FCM supports high and normal
priority messages.
High priority messages wake the
device from doze which mean
that's a lot of them aren't good
for system health.  If the task
can run in less than ten
seconds, you can execute it
right away.  Schedule a yob with
>> DAN GALPIN: Work manager.
Ideal lie, these are user
centric tasks that run for a
long time.  Examples are maps,
navigation, fitness tracking,
playing music.
>> ERIC KUXHAUSEN: In play
store, we use a foreground
service when we restore apps.
This is okay because it's long
running work in response to user
interaction.  But, it's not as
fun as listening to music.
>> FRED CHUNG: So the good news
is that these other things are
already impacting your apps but
perhaps you haven't
noticed yet
.  So, in Android N, new photo
broadcasts no longer happen,
right, but can be replaced by
trigger content URIs for jobs --
I mean works.
So, it is what it looks like
using the new work manager API.
>> DAN GALPIN: Now if your app
is running in the background on
an Android O plus device the
location service computes a new
location for your app less often
even if your app requests more
frequent updates.  Even full
Wi-Fi scans are only performed
for background apps a few times
every hour so if you're called
more application the Wi-Fi
manager will actually just
provide cache results.
Now, if you need to know when
the user
reaches a specific location, use
geo fencing.
Now, there are only 100
geofences that can be active so
if you need more sites
that than that you can actually
use regional geofences to swap
in.
That being said, beacons are
awesome.  You can use the nearby
notifications API, and that's
important, particularly
if you're a certain prolific
coffee vendor.
>> ERIC KUXHAUSEN: You can also
use the batch version of the
fuse location.  Specific face a
maximum weight location that is
acceptable for your use case and
the system will attempt to batch
location updates so that your
app is woken up less frequently.
This will optimize battery use.
You can also use passive
location that
enables your app to
opportunisticallyically update
on other apps of keep in mind,
though, that if your apps are
tied to anything such as network
throws, you should throttle
those as well.
>> FRED CHUNG: So through
batching and passive location,
we can work with location
updates in a power efficient
manner.  Next, let's go through
some related improvements in the
platform.
So
in the past several Android
we've introduced a series of
battery optimization based on
referring and restricting
background tasks.  You probably
are familiar with some of these
already.
For example, a device could
enter doze when the device is
unplugged and when the device
isn't being used for quite some
time.
In doze, apps have to finish any
pending jobs in some periodic
maintenance windows.
>> DAN GALPIN: On N plus, doze
was extended for on the go use
cases such as
when a device is sitting in the
useer's pock.
Now, app standby was introduced
when where it imposes task
restrictions based upon app
usage.
>> ERIC KUXHAUSEN: And let me
tell you about the brand new
stuff.
In Android P, usage based
restrictions are applied in a
more fine grained way.  You may
have already learned about this
in the earlier I/O talk, don't
let your app drain your users'
battery.  Apps will be added to
one of the standby buckets based
on usage.
The system applies progressively
more restrictions on your app as
it goes from the -- to the rare
bucket.
In addition, battery
saver allows you to have
additional battery life.
This leads to some degradation
in
functionality
such as location requests not
being available, however it
allows your battery to last a
little bit longer.
>> FRED CHUNG: So the features
we gist discussed have additive
impacts on alarms, network
access, and FCM messages so we
really strongly encourage
everyone to thoroughly test
these scenarios
within your applications.
>> DAN GALPIN: And the good news
is that there are tools for
that.  For example, this adb
command forces the device into
an idle state, making all apps
dose.
>> ERIC KUXHAUSEN: To test app
standby, first simulate unplug
the device and
then use get and set demand to
get the device in and out of
standby.
>> FRED CHUNG: For app standby
buckets you can get and set
buckets for a given
package using simulate commands
but remember to simulate
unplugging your device before
testing.  There's also framework
APIs available to do this.
Finally, these are the commands
for testing battery saver.  One
note is that if your app's UI
has a dark theme, you can
consider enabling the dark theme
when battery saver is
turned on to further conserve
power on OLED devices.  Through
power manager, you can check
with an API and listen to a
broadcast to do that.
>> DAN GALPIN: So there are lots
of ways to make your apps do
auto cool stuff in the
background without using
foreground services.
Leverage the new functionality
in the WorkManager, use
efficient location strategies,
use the new APIs and make sure
to tell us what doesn't meet
your needs by submitting
feedback through the
issue tracker
>> FRED CHUNG: So right after
this talk
you'll probably be busy updating
your target SDKs which is all
good.  While you're at it we
strongly encourage you to check
out some selective modern
features on Android that are
relevant to your use cases.  So
you have to have, for example,
notification channels to your
app on O.  Otherwise, well,
notifications won't show which
won't be good.  Plan your
channels carefully so that your
users can selectively turn off
notifications that they don't
want.
>> DAN GALPIN: Back one slide,
please, on devices where the
play store implemented support
for notification channels, we
see a fewer percent for user
disabling all of our
notifications.
So if your app is using a
translucent status bar, you can
use the inset APIs
to make sure your code doesn't
assume status bar is a fixed
size.  If you're using the
navigation drawer, this is tomb
very common.  If you target P,
you can also do something
interesting in that area.  Now,
public service announcement.
You don't have to put your
system image on your only
device.  If you haven't used the
emulator in a while, it's pretty
usement o.  Recently, we've
added support for
super fast loading along with AI
sports.  On any device, you can
simulate display cutout through
the developer options.  This
ends the public service
announcement.
>> FRED CHUNG: Great.
So, long aspects ratio screens
of it's
become a friend for OEM to be
shipping device like these with
screens longer than the 16 by
nine aspect ratio.
Make sure your apps' immersive
experiences fully take advantage
of these capabilities, which is
pretty usement o.
As a last resort, the system
still
provides you a way to declare
your maximum supported aspect
ratio.
>> And seriously, do you really
want
letter boxes
.
>> Now, consider taking
advantage for
use cases such as video,
business
tracking or Pokemon Go.
Multiple display also allows you
to
launch an activity on a second
display.  The only thing you
have to consider here is it has
a second configuration which is
going to be different from the
one on your app most likely so
be careful not to make
assumptions about hardware
configuration.
>> And in conclusion, Android
development has evolved to mean
using
the latest APIs, enable better
battery life, smoother
multitasking, supporting the
latest hardware and platform
features and taking advantage of
Jetpack to build a modern,
testable architecture.  Thank
you
(applause)
Actually, no, no, no.  There's
actually one more thing.
Android is actually restricting
the
use of some non-SDK interfaces
in developer preview one and you
saw this because we actually
warned you with like
toast and log entries if these
methods were used but you'll
notice if you're testing against
DP2, some of these
methods will just
cease to work.  To help you out
in the future, we've actually
added a new VM policy for strict
mode that you can use to turn on
and detect all non-SDK usage
which is really important
because this non-SDK usage may
be happening in your library so
this is a really great way to
actually make sure that your app
is going to be compatible going
forward because we don't
guarantee the compatibility of
any non-SDK API.
And so, that really is it now.
If you haven't been paying
attention in the last 30
minutes, that's okay.  Because
clearly my jokes need work.
If you're an engineer, hopefully
much of the information shared
today was a review for you and
we hope you found the tips
useful.
>> FRED CHUNG: So, if you're a
PM and
your ad is not quite targeting
26 yet, it's not too late to
plan out, work with your teams
to figure out how much work is
need and in fact we prepared a
guide
on Android developer sites to
help people understand based on
your current release the amount
of work needed so that we can
collectively push the ecosystem
forward.  Thank you very much
(applause)
>> So, let us know what you
think.
Now, if you don't ever want to
see us present here at I/O
again, this is your chance to
make sure this never happens
again.
>> So, just target straight to
P.
>> So, thank you very much.
>> Thank you
(applause)
(Session was concluded at 4:56
PM CT)
***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.  This text,
document, or file is not to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
***
REALTIME CAPTIONING ON THIS
SCREEN
GOOGLE I/O
I/O 2018
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CALIFORNIA
MAY 10, 2018
STAGE 2
3:30 PM
BUILD ENGAGING CONVERSATIONS FOR
GOOGLE ASSISTANT
WITH DIALOGFLOW
T519D2
>> ALL RIGHT. HEY, EVERYONE.
MY MAIM IS Dan and this is Matt
and we're both Googlers who work
on a product called Dialogflow.
So, I wanted to say first, thank
you so much for coming.
We've been having an amazing I/O
and we're super excited to share
our talk with you.  You've
probably heard a lot over the
last few days about how
important the Google Assistant
is for our vision for how
computers can help people get
things done.  The Assistant
works across dozens of device
types and makes the most of the
best features of each device.
That could mean the quick
at-a-glance display of the smart
watch and it could
mean the benefits of no screen
at all.
The Assistant is now available
on over 500 million devices so
that makes this a really
important platform to build for.
So, the system is really smart
and
we've made it do some super cool
stuff but the real power of
platforms comes from their
developers.
So, how do we empower our
developers to extend the
Assistant and do things we never
could have imagined?  This is
where Dialogflow comes in of
we've taken what we learned from
building amazing conversational
experiences and we've built a
tool that allows any developer
to do the same thing.  This
session, we're going to tell you
all about Dialogflow, we're
going to tell what you it does,
where it fits, and we're going
to show you how to build a
sophisticated action for the
Google Assistant in just a few
minutes.
We're also going to talk about a
few upgrades we've made based on
feedback
we've had from our awesome
community.  So, as you saw in
our developer keynote, we've had
really great momentum and growth
this year.  We've had half a
million developers use
Dialogflow, which is a 250
percent increase since this time
last year.
Google's developers are
obviously really excited to use
our ML tech in their work.
We've also got brands all around
the world using Dialogflow and
they're building some really
amazing stuff.
So if you want to see some case
studies, you can check our
website to see some partner
experiences using the website.
All right, let's get technical.
So, before we go further, let's
go over some basics.
An action is a third party
experience for the system and
there are many ways a user can
invoke your action.
First, they can just ask the
Assistant
for your action by name.
Or maybe the Assistant might
suggest your action based on its
functionality.  Once invoked,
the Assistant is going to hand
conversation control over to
Dialogflow.  Dialogflow
understands conversational
language, and it will hold a
conversation with your users
based on a structure that you
define.  You can then connect
this conversation with your
business logic to make things
happen and generate replies.
To define the conversation,
you'll use Dialogflow's UI.
And it's a web app that even
nondeveloppers can use.
There's no coding requirement
for simple acts.  Under the
hood, this all uses machine
learning and natural language
understanding tools but won't
need a PhD to make use of then.
For more complex actions,
connecting actions with your
code is super easy and you can
even use our embedded Cloud
functions with Firebase editor.
You just tell Dialogflow at
which point the conversation it
should communication with your
code.
Dialogflow then makes an HTTP
request
with JSON describing what the
user wants
and you can use this to
construct a complex response or
to look something up and
generally make stuff happen.
So, we want to show you how easy
it is to get started with
Dialogflow, and over the next
few minutes, we're going to
build an action from scratch for
an imaginary local business.
Our business is going to be a
bike repair shop.  Our action's
going to work like a helpful
store clerk and it's going to
allow our bike repair shop's
customers to check the shop's
opening hours and book an
appointment to service their
bike.
So, here's what's going to
happen during the demo.  First,
we're going to walk you through
how to respond to user queries
with a powerful concept called
the intent.
We're then going to show you how
to
extract detailed information
from user's
queries like time and dates and
we're going to demonstrate how
to connect your action to
business logic that will store
appointments in a Google
calendar.  Finally, we're going
to integrate our action with a
Google Assistant and check it
out.  So, to get started, I'm
going to hand it over to Matt
and he's going to demonstrate
how the finished action is
going to work on his shiny new
pixel book.
>> MATT CARROLL: Thanks, Dan.
Can we go ahead and switch to
the demo -- oh, there we go.
So, before we get started
building, I'm just going to give
you guys a quick demo of what
we're going to build.  Right now
on the left hand side of the
screen we have thele Google
Assistant up
on the pixel book and we'll say,
talk to
my bike shop to invoke to
invocate our action.  Right now,
Google Assistant to our action
the bike shop.  Right now we're
going to set up an appointment
and it's going to ask us what
day we want to come in.  So
we're going to say next Friday.
And then it asks us what time,
and we'll say 3:00 PM.  And
right now, we're, the Cloud
function is actually adding an
event to our calendar you can
see there and asking us what
kind of appointment.  So, I'm
going to say tune-up.  And then
we can see our action is
confirmed the appointment and
ended the conversation.
So, now let's build it.  So,
we're going to switch to our
Dialogflow here and log in.  So,
this is Dialogflow's console.
On the left you'll see a panel
where you have all the main
concepts that you need to lose
to close the Dialogflow agent
and in the middle, we have the
panel where you use all these
main concepts.  Right now, it's
a list of intent and on the
right, we have a simulator where
you can try out your Dialogflow
agent as you're building it so
let's go ahead and try it out.
We'll say hello.
So we can see that the default
welcome intent here was matched
and if we look, open up the
default welcome intent, you can
see that we had the response
high.  So, that's not quite what
we want to say since we have a
bike shop, so let's change that
response up and say, welcome to
my bike shop.  How can I help?
So, we'll try it again.
So, now we're adding a training
phrase here so that our high
query is understood and the
agent is training and
using this high example as a
training phrase for a machine
learning model that's running in
the background that
will identify incoming requests
to this welcome intent.
So, we'll try hi again, and now
we can see that our response
correctly identified and we send
back the correct response.  So,
let's create our own intent now.
So, we'll go to the navigation
pin on the left where it says
intents and click this little
plus sign so create our own
intent.  And we'll type in
hours, so this will be our
intent that we're going to
create for any intention the
user has to know the hours our
bike is open.  So the first
thing we need to do is add
training phrases.  These
training phrases are the basis
for the machine learning model
so we need to think of things
users might say when they want
to know the hours of our bike
shop.  Do a few examples here.
How late can I come in?
They might say, what are your
hours directly?
Or they might say, when do you
open?
So I'll go ahead and save that
and then Dialogflow will start
this training process using
these training phrases and all
that's happening.  We're going
to add a response.
So, down here with click add
response
and then we'll say, we're open
from 9:00
AM to 5:00 PM every week day.
We'll click save and we'll try
querying this out.
All right, are you open now?
So, now we can see the hours
intent
was matched down here and send
back the correct response, we're
open from nine to five every
day.  And now I just want to
take a moment and notice the
query, are you open now isn't
really similar to any training
phrases we have.  When do you
open?  What are your hours?  How
late do you come in?  So, this
is the power of Dialogflow.  If
you can imagine trying to write
a regular expression to match
every instance of these four
examples as well as thousands of
ways that someone could
ask, when is your store open,
this is where Dialogflow becomes
really powerful and allows your
users to talk to you in a
natural conversational way.  So,
new let's take a closer look at
the response.
It's a little bit generic so
we're open from nine to five
every week day.
We're not actually answer the
question, are you open now?
In a normal conversation, you
might expect more contextual
information.  Oh, we're open
until five today.
So, for that, we need to know
what the hour is and if that
falls within our open range.
So we need to use fulfillment.
Fulfillment is how you connect
your
Dialogflow agent to code.
In this case, we have an inline
editor where I've already
written some code.  We can see
the hours function.  We can
check if the store is currently
open.  If it is, we give a
response that says we're open
now and we will be open until
five.  If not, we tell them when
we're open next.  One more thing
we need to do to connect this
code to our Dialogflow agent.
That's where we go to dialogue
intent, scroll all the way down
to fulfillment and then enable
this intent.  So, once we do
that, if we try our query again.
Are you open now?
We can see right now, so right
now, the hours and intent is
calling the web book and comes
back with the correct
response of, we're open now
and we close at 5:00 PM today.
So that calculation was made and
sent back the proper response.
All right, so now let's try
something a little bit more
complex.  We're going to create
an intent for making an
appointment.  So, we'll call it
the make appointment intent.
And for this intent, we'll need
a few more examples because
there's many different ways that
a user might say, I want it make
an appointment.  So we'll go
through those right now.
I'd like to get a bike tune-up.
I'd like to schedule an
appointment next Thursday.
Can I schedule service for noon?
Can I set up an appointment for
my bike
tomorrow at 2:00 PM?
And the last one, I'd like to
come in
at 9:00 AM on May 11th.
So, now you can see we have a
few
things going on here that are
different from our previous
examples.
So, Dialogflow has highlighted a
few of the entities that are
present in our users examples.
So, entities and Dialogflow has
several entities built in so we
can extract data from what users
are saying and use it in this
case to schedule a bike
appointment.  So, all of the red
highlighted items are times and
all of the yellow highlighted
items are dates.
So, if you scroll down
, we can see that these are
listed as
parameters so we have
.  We want the time and date the
user
specified so that we can confirm
the right appointment time so
we'll go ahead and add a
response here, and say great.
I've set up your appointment the
dollar sign date.
So, this takes the value from
what the user says and then puts
it in our response and then at
dollar sign time, so this will
add the same thing for the time
value.
See you then.
I'll go ahead and save that and
then we'll try this out.
So, I want an appointment
tomorrow at 3:00 PM.
So now you can see that
the Dialogflow correctly maps an
maps and it's easily parsable on
our website and correctly inputs
those values back into our
response.  So, to actually make
an appointment, we need a date
and a  time.
So, we need to make sure that
the user provides both those
pieces of data so we're going to
go to the parameter table and
make both of these parameters
required.  Now, when a parameter
is required, we
can define a prompt so that if a
user doesn't require a date and
time, we can ask them for it.
So in this case, we'll add a
prompt that says, what day do
you want to come in?
For our time we'll add a prompt
that says, what time works for
you.  So, let's try that out.
Say, I need an appointment.
Oops.
Let's try appointment.
So, now that we've matched the
make appointment intent, you can
see that the response instead of
our response to find here, we
hit one of our prompts that
says, what day do you want to
come in so we'll go ahead and
answer that question, say, next
Friday.  And what time works for
you?  We'll say 11:00 AM.  And
now you can see that this has
been filled in correctly by
Dialogflow and we
get the ultimate response back
there.
So, now that we've set up an
appointment, we might want to
get some additional information
from the user about the
appointment so we might want to
know what kind of appointment
type.
So we'll ask them a question and
say,
do you need a repair or just a
tune-up.
So now we need a way to capture
the answer to this question.
If they want a repair or a
tune-up so
a dialogue flow already has
these built-in entities for date
and time but you can also create
your own entities so we'll go
ahead and do that now.  On the
left panel again, you can see
the left hand button so we'll
create an entity.  We'll call it
appointment type.
And then we'll add entries for
our appointment type entity.
So, in this case, we'll have a
service option and a fix option.
So, we'll enter in the first
value, service.  And then we can
also enter in synonym values for
each of these entities.  So,
someone might not actually say
the word service but they might
say another word that means the
same thing so we can
define synonyms that will map
back to
this cannonnical value.  So
instead of saying service,
someone might say overhaul.
They might say maintenance.
They might say tune-up.  Or they
might say tune up with a space
in it.
For our other value, we have
fix.  Someone might say repair,
mend.  They might say their bike
is broken.  They might say they
have a flat tire.  Or they might
say, fixed.  So, we'll say that.
So now that we have an
appointment
entity, we need to create an
intent to capture it.  In the
case of our intents we only
really need to capture this
appointment
type entity
after our intent has been
matched.  So we want to make a
new intent.  To r that,
something called follow-up
intent.
So if we hover over add
appointment, you can see
follow-up.  So we'll create a
custom follow-up.  So this new
intent listed with that
arrow means this intent can only
be matched after the intent.
So, for this, we just asked the
user if they want a service or
if they want to fix their bike
so we'll enter in some examples
of how users might answer that
question.
It might say I need a repair.
Or they might say, can you
service my bike?
So now you can see as before
with the built-in entities
Dialogflow was
directly identified for our
custom entity that we just
created since we need to know
this information, we're going to
make it required and we'll add a
prompt for it as well.
We can service or repair your
bike.  Which one would you like?
So, now for our response here,
it would be nice to confirm our
actual appointment time and date
and after they've said what
appointment type they have, but
if you'll see here in the
parameter table, we actually
don't have the time or date here
so how do we get this value.
For that, we're going to need to
dig a
little deeper into how follow-up
intents work.  So, follow-up
intents work through something
called context.
So, once we added this follow-up
intent, output was added to make
appointment.
There are two types of, output
context and input context.
Output context attach a context
to a session after the intent
has been
matched so in this case, after
our make appointment attempt has
been matched, the make
appointment follow-up context
will be added to the session.
Next, let's take a look at our
follow-up intent.  For our
follow-up intent, we have the
same value, make appointment
follow-up context, except
instead of the output context
it's in the input context.  So,
this makes the make appointment
custom or our follow-up intent
only get matches once the make
appointment follow-up context is
attached to the session so in
our case, the only time that the
make appointment follow-up
context is attached to the
session is attached to our
appointment.  So, this means
that this make appointment
custom follow-up intent will
only be matched after our make
appointment parent intent.
In addition to controlling the
flow in
how intents are matched,
contexts also
store parameter value so we can
use the
value to make appointment
follow-up to reference time and
date that we previously gathered
in the make
appointment intent so we'll go
ahead and do that now.
We'll say, okay, we'll schedule
a dollar sign appointment so
this is grabbing, fixing or
servicing the bike just like
last time now we want to insert
the date.  So we'll do pound,
make appointment, follow-up, do
add date.  Then we'll add the
context value dot time.  So,
this will grab our time and date
value from the previous intent.
We'll see you then.  All right.
Now, instead of trying this out
on Dialogflow simulator on the
right, why
don't we see what this looks
like for Dialogflow assistant?
We'll see a tab called
integrations.  This integrations
page -- the Dialogflow has with
other chat and voice providers.
So you can use any of these to
deploy your Dialogflow.
For now we're going to start out
with the Google Assistant.
You can see information about
how Dialogflow works with Google
Assistant but for now we're just
going to try it out.
So, flipping tests is the
actions on Google console.
It's where you define all your
information about your app like
con vocation.
My test app is a special time
just like you when you're trying
to test but you can enter any
names into your brand once you
get the actions console.  For
now, we'll try talk to my test
app.
>> Okay. Here as the test
version of my test app.
>> Hi, welcome to my bike shop.
How can I help?
>> MATT CARROLL: So what's
happened now
is we've invocated our action
and that sends the request to
Dialogflow which matches the
welcome intent which sends back
the response we defined earlier.
So, let's try this out.  Can I
book an appointment for tomorrow
at noon?
>> What time works for you?
>> MATT CARROLL: Noon. There we
go.
>> Great. I've set up your
appointment for the 11th of May,
2018, at 12 hours, zero minutes
and zero seconds.  The do you
need a repair or just a tune-up?
>> MATT CARROLL: So now we see
it's matched the make
appointment intent and now we're
going to try out our follow-up
intent.  So we'll say, I need a
repair.
>> Okay.
We'll schedule a fix for the
11th of May 2018, at 12 hours,
zero minutes and zero seconds,
we'll see you then.
>> MATT CARROLL: So now you can
see that it correctly identified
the repair word and mapped it to
the word fix so in our response,
it says, okay, we'll schedule a
word fix and also grabbed the
time and date from the context
to surface that to the user as
well.  So, now that we've got an
action fully
working, I'm going to pass it
back to Dan who's going to talk
about some of the new features
we've built in Dialogflow over
the next year and some of the
more features I didn't get to go
over
(applause)
>> DANIEL IMRIE-SITUNAYAKE: All
right.
You should take a bow.  So,
yeah, I hope that we've shown
you how quickly you can build a
really powerful Assistant action
with Dialogflow.  If the few
minutes we've built an engaging
conversational agent.  We
connected it to our code.  And
we've been able to deploy and
test it immediately.
An the really crazy thing is
that
after review, this action will
be available on over 500 million
devices with no install
required.
People just have to say the name
of your action.  So,
conversational experiences are a
pretty new idea, and building
your first agent can be hard
because there's a
whole set of concepts that may
be unfamiliar for you.  So we've
built a lot of tools that will
help make it easier to get
started.
Of Dialogflow comes with 45
prebuilt agents that you can use
as a starting point when you're
developing.  We've covered a
load of different real
world scenarios like alarms,
built in tickets.  All you need
to do is import the intents and
entity and customize them to
support and suit your action.
In fact, every single Dialogflow
agent
comes equipped with over 50
system entities.  These cover
common concepts, including
numbers, dates and times,
amounts with units and
geography.  Dialogflow can
extract values based on these
with no additional work so you
can understand your customers
and help them get things done
without a lot of overhead.  We
also have a growing library of
sample agents that demonstrate
how to use our features and
these are
referenced in our docs and on
GitHub,
and for I/O this year E we've
added a new feature where you
can open it with one click and
try it out so this will deploy
the agent and fulfillment code
so you can customize it and be
up and running straight away.
Speaking of our docs, we've also
built in interactive Dialogflow
agents.  You can play with real
world examples
to help you run with real world
topics.
We're regularly employing new
world tutorials and we just
published another brief getting
started video to our Dialogflow
YouTube.  Once you've learned
the basics, we provide tools to
help you do really powerful
stuff so Dialogflow will help
you extend your actions over
time so you
can improve your customer
experience and performance.
For example, natural
conversations branch in complex
and unpredictable ways.
Things that are discussed
earlier in a conversation can
have an impact later on.
And in the past, conversational
platforms require you to hard
code everything which is really
brittle and
difficult to do anything to
improve over time.  Fortunately,
Dialogflow's context allows you
to shape the flow of a
conversation without having to
predict every possible twist and
turn ahead of time.  This can
help you get beyond the idea of
a menu-based phone conversation
and create genuine conversation
between people and computers.
Once your action is up and
running, you'll have a ton of
log conversations and you can
use the status to improve your
actions.  Our training  features
will show you
all of the past interactions.
You can also create new intents
when customers ask for something
that you didn't handle.
Every feature we add is guided
by these three goals.  We
want to create an excellent full
stack experience for our
developers.
We want the best possible
natural language and
understanding for machine
learning and we want it to be
easy to integrate and scale
across any conversational
platform.  We use developer
feedback.  I want to show you
some of the features that we've
added since last year's I/O.
First, we've heard that you want
better insight into how
conversations are going so we've
included our history view and
made it much easier for
developers to see how that agent
is being used.
Now you can filter on dates and
platforms and you can search
through
logs to find particular
interactions that are
noteworthy.
This will help improve your
debugging experience and help
you get to a better agent over
time.
We've also been working really
hard to support all the
languages that your users speak
and today we support 29
languages and nine locales.
We recently added support for
languages including hindi, Thai
and Indonesian.  We've also
added multiple agents so you can
build one agent that works for
all of your users across the
world.
Many of our customers have been
asking
us for an enterprise solution so
this
year we introduced Dialogflow
enterprise edition.  This brings
Dialogflow to Google Cloud
which means you get enterprise
grade compliance and customer
support on our Cloud services.
So
Ubisoft built their personal
assistant, Sam, and Sam was able
to understand 88
of players' requests in the
first three months of their
beta.
So, I hope you're feeling
excited to get started dealing
with Dialogflow.
There have been tons of really
amazeing Assistant sessions at
this year's I/O.  You can fink
find links on the recording
sites so you can enjoy them at
your leisure.  You should also
make sure to check out our code
apps which will guide you toward
your first action.  Your
feedback is crucial to us and we
really hope you've enjoyed this
session so we'd also love for
you to head over
to the I/O website.  It's super
easy to get started with
Dialogflow and we've put
together a page full of links
that can help you get up and
running.  You'll also find links
to our online communities where
our whole team is hanging out
and we can help answer your
questions.
Also, don't be shy about
tweeting our AoG Devs hashtag.
So we hope you've had a really
amazing I/O and that you go on
and have a ton of
fun building actions with Google
with Dialogflow.
Thank you very much
(applause)
(Session was concluded at 5:59
PM CT)
***
This text, document, or file is
based on live transcription.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART), captioning,
and/or live transcription are
provided in order to facilitate
communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.  This text,
document, or file is not to be
distributed or used in any way
that may violate copyright law.
***